You don't want a hype man, you want a cyborg?
I want a repository of wisdom and information.
But instead you got me.
(upbeat music plays)
(laughter)
Hey everybody, welcome to ROLL ON,
where after a mini globe trotting respite,
meets writer deadline schedule,
of delaying cluster (indistinct).
The boys are finally back in the lime green chairs,
me here and across from me over there once again,
the Vertical Blue to my horizontal pinstripe,
the chef to my chef.
Sorry, I know I told that joke last time,
but I had to, hit that one again.
If you know, you know,
if you don't, I don't know what to tell you.
Mr. Adam Skolnick,
to break down matters important and trivial.
So today, we're going to regale ourselves
and probably no one, (laughing) nobody else,
with an update on personal goings on,
we're gonna recap some highlights from Leadville,
The Bahamas, Rome, London, Manhattan,
many global Ports Of Call.
We're gonna do a bit on wealth inequality.
We're gonna perhaps share a few things,
we've been enjoying respectively if we have time,
we probably won't, we will see.
Of course, answer a few listener/viewer questions
and much more.
So, before I toss it over to you, Adam,
there were a lot of tweets and comments and DMS,
because we, you know, we,
we were off our biweekly schedule
without going deep on what biweekly means.
(both laugh)
People demanding their ROLL ON,
wanting to know if I was scouring the earth in my travels,
looking for Adam,
who was hiding.
No.
Demanding their Skolnick fix.
So, happy to be across from you today,
and I wanted to kick it off
by bequeathing you with your first fan letter?
Oh.
Fan mail
that came here to the studio.
Fan snail mails?
Yes.
More fan mail for Skolnick.
From the St. George's,
St. George's school, Building Fine Young Men.
Yeah. So.
One Boy at a Time.
There you go.
Well?
Maybe open that later.
We'll open that at a different time.
Yeah.
Thank you.
The reason for my pinstriped suit today,
is of course, because this is episode 700.
You look great.
700 episodes.
700. Amazing.
And I'm glad that I'm doing it with you.
We can celebrate together.
Thanks man.
You've been a, a big part of,
how many have we done at this point?
How many ROLL ONs?
I really don't know.
It has to be,
I would say probably 30 or 40.
You think?
That many?
Maybe, maybe not.
Maybe 25?
Maybe not.
Yeah. Maybe 25 or so.
Somebody out there counting.
We'll figure it out.
Yeah.
I could probably look.
Hmm.
I have it, I have it somewhere,
You have it?
on the wall of my cell,
where I live.
Yeah, you're right.
I scratch it.
In shock.
Yeah. coz I get out,
With your fingernails?
I get out for this.
You go,
we put you back in your cell.
Yeah. I can come back,
I can come out to work and then I have to go back.
But when you go back,
you're just reading and studying
and preparing for the next ROLL ON.
That's all I do is I focus
It's exclusive. Yeah.
Yeah. I have, I, I,
I go to sleep with one of those eye masks
and the eye masks have the shape of this microphone,
and that's all I see.
See, I would prefer
like some sort of Google glass contraption.
Would you?
Where you're reading all the time,
developing material for the show.
Interesting.
And maybe some earbuds,
where you're listening to conversations and podcasts.
So you're just consuming as much content as possible
and synthesizing it during your REM cycle.
You don't want a hype man, you want a cyborg?
I, I want a repository of wisdom and information.
But instead you got me.
Like, yeah, but you know.
I find it funny that
you are scouring the earth looking for me
when I never leave now...
I know. (laughing)
All of a sudden,
all of a sudden I went from like
never leaving town.
I was in London out.
Somebody said a joke like,
to somebody out of town.
"Are you looking for Adam? Like where is he?
Is it like a Where's Waldo thing?"
I'm always in the same place.
You're easy to track down.
I'm too easy to track.
And generally available.
Like if I call or text,
you pretty much get back to me right away.
You can't be too busy.
I am, but you know, I'm busy.
You have other things.
I got, I got...
At some point,
hopefully we can talk about the other things
that you've been working on.
Yes. we will. We will.
I, you know, it is funny though,
because it's been...
For so long,
a lot of my work life was always out of town,
Mm-hmm.
and you know,
to be so, like I feel civilized and I, it's...
You're an adult.
I know, but I don't necessarily like it.
( Adam laughing)
Yeah.
We're planning on next year being a travel year,
next year is a travel year.
We're gonna, we're gonna,
we're gonna do some trips so, you know,
we've done a few little, little jaunts,
but we're gonna do some proper trips hopefully next year.
That's the goal.
Yeah, we went to Mexico.
Yeah, we did that. We did that.
I mean that's (indistinct).
But you're, you're a,
you're a lonely planet off the beaten path.
Atlas Obscura kind of guy.
You know what I'm doing now, to fill that niche?
I'm watching the...
I just finished watching the first season of Parts Unknown.
(Adam laughs)
Of Parts Unknown?
Yeah.
Going back.
It's the only,
cause it's the only season available on HBO.
You're living, living vicariously.
Yeah. I'm just, what I'm doing,
I'm, I'm, I'm, I wanna be up to,
up to the minute on things for you,
so I watch news from the 2013.
Right.
That's what I like to do.
Well, Parts Unknown,
does that state your, you know,
wild hair desire to be exploring,
or does it make you feel more anxious
about being at home?
You know, I don't feel...
so, I don't feel too anxious about it,
because there, you know,
for every time there is a season,
or every season there's a time, whatever,
it's the way it is, but...
Something about turning in there too.
Yes, but I def, definitely like,
wets my appetite for like
to get out there and you know,
Zuma loves to cruise.
I mean, he loves traveling.
We, when we went down to North County, San Diego,
just for five days, he was like, happy to cruise.
Like he's, he, anywhere we go,
whether it's Marina del Rey, La Paz, whatever,
he is just always ready to like,
walk around and walk ahead and look around.
That he is.
And he's now just recently gotten more social,
but for a long time,
and even still has it,
he has this thing that I call 50 Shades of Adios.
Hmm.
And that is,
when people come up to him...
This is like a new book.
He's a cute kid.
Right? I mean, come on.
Yeah.
I mean, listen.
I know I don't put him on social media,
just trust me.
It's not me as a parent saying,
it, it's that, he's, he's objectively a cute kid.
Of course it's not you as a parent saying that.
Yeah. He's objective
It's completely objective.
It's an objective thing.
And so sometimes people come up to him
and they wanna lean down,
"Oh, hi. Hi."
And he'll say, "Adios," coz he's bilingual.
Mm-hmm.
Adios. That's what he says.
And they think, a lot of times they think it's cute.
They think, "Oh, he's so cute,"
coz of the cute kid speaking Spanish,
they think it's very cute.
I take him to the bakery,
I say, "What do you want today at the bakery's?"
Always croissant by the way,
the kid loves croissants,
but in, the guy comes over,
"Yeah. What can I get you?"
"Adios."
(Rich laughing)
That's what he says to the guy.
And, but sometimes like you, last, you call,
we, we talked last night,
he said Ola to you,
and then when it was time to say goodbye,
he says adios in a nice way.
So sometimes adios means goodbye.
Sometimes it means, "Take a hike, pal."
Like, "Fuck off."
Yeah. Take a hike.
Yeah.
Well, what I hear in that is,
yeah, on the one hand it's sort of the,
the infants version of I bid you good day, sir.
Yes.
Right?
Like get away from me.
Yeah.
But also, there is a flexing of healthy boundaries, right?
He's like, I don't need you in my space right now.
Right.
Yeah.
He's like...
Good for him.
And sometimes he, it's not like, it's kind of a,
a nicer adios, like, "Adios," and he just turns and bails.
So it's not always, "You have to leave,"
but I feel like...
It's all in the inflection.
It's kind of how Camiolo,
when we hear noise in the next room,
you know, when that, I've heard him do it.
He goes outside and he is like, "Hey pal? Adios!"
(Rich laughing)
Yeah.
I've heard him do it.
A little New York energy.
Yeah. But, yeah.
I like that.
So, so that's happening.
Went to the Red Hot Chili Peppers.
Nice
At SoFi...
Mm.
In late July.
You've been gone a long...
We have been apart,
so I haven't been able to tell you, um,
did you watch that untitled documentary that April found?
I didn't, I, I've been meaning to watch it.
I love the lure of the Red Hot Chili Peppers.
And I've actually been thinking about them a fair amount,
because I spent a little bit of time
with Rick Rubin recently.
Oh. That's good.
And we did a podcast that will be coming out,
not for a while, not until the new year.
And of course, he's worked with them extensively
including on, on the latest album,
but I know you're a mega fan, right?
Well, I wasn't always, April is,
but I wasn't always,
but because the problem with me,
when I was a young snot,
is that, if you were popular,
I automatically didn't really want anything to do with you,
you know, like as a band, or a film or whatever,
I was that kind of an obnoxious guy,
but I always enjoyed the music.
It's fun music, party music,
but I didn't realize
how much I actually probably aligned with them,
cause I didn't pay attention too much
to who like Anthony and Flea were and all that.
And obviously I think,
I think of Californication as their, their best album.
That's my personal opinion.
It's my favorite.
Yeah. And it's, it's, they're at that,
they're 37, I think, when they're recording that record,
and, and, and touring around with it.
So it's like, in some ways it's like,
they've, they've gotten to this
kind of place of greater wisdom,
and, and still creatively just incredible,
and, and a lot of energy.
And so, I know all that retroactively,
because I've just been enjoying the music more recently
since I've been with April,
but April's like obsessed with them,
knows everybody.
Like, I didn't know the whole thing about John Frusciante
or any of them.
Frusciante.
Yeah. Frusciante.
Right.
I didn't know about his whole ordeal...
It's been a saga.
And what he went through.
That guy's a genius though.
A genius.
And like just the fact that,
so now that I'm looking back and kind of a late,
like a late blooming super fan, which I,
which I guess I am,
April found this great YouTube documentary that was,
I think unreleased.
And it's all about touring
behind the Californication record.
There's there's a,
a documentary people may have seen called Funky Monks,
which is about Blood Sugar Sex Magik.
recording that record,
and that's really good,
but this other one,
is like another level.
Like they have, Chris Rock comes in,
Woody Harrelson makes a cameo,
Julia Butterfly Hill,
who was in the top of the tree, she's in it.
They bring in like Buddhist teachers.
They bring in all sorts of people,
and they talk to them
in basically the Green Room, backstage.
And they have, I mean,
it's a phenomenal piece of verite, and I love it.
It's so weird and quirky.
And you get to know who these guys are a little bit more.
And, and so I, I recommend it.
Well, you should put, we'll put the link up.
Yeah. Put the link,
I'll put the link in the show notes
and I'll make a mental note to watch that.
Yeah.
It's, you know, I mean,
whatever you think of the Red Hot Chili Peppers,
clearly they're, you know,
one of Los Angeles's greatest rock bands of all time,
like they are Los Angeles, right?
I think they are,
I think they are the greatest band in history of LA,
cause like, The Doors.
The Doors.
Would be up there,
so you'd have The Doors, but, but the,
The Peppers, the Chili Peppers,
really personify LA in a way that The Doors do not.
(indistinct) Los Angeles
Yeah, yeah. It's that good.
Right.
It is impossible to drive down Melrose
and pass Fairfax High School,
without thinking about those guys.
Right.
Coz they all met there when they were like 14.
And have been together since.
Well, the two guys did.
and then the other, the first guitarist.
Flea and Anthony met there.
Yeah.
And their, their other guitarist.
I think the original guitarist.
Yeah. I met Chad, spent a little bit of time.
Yeah. And Chad.
We were both at, at like a,
an event at The Nantucket Project a couple years ago.
Anthony's sober.
Like I think an, and he's point doom I'm pretty sure,
or somewhere around here.
Yeah. I know he is kicked around here.
He's local. He should be here.
I've never, I've never met him. I, I don't know.
He's kinda sitting this...
Flea is the guy I want in the seat.
You want, you just gonna get both men.
His, his memoir is incredible.
I have it right over there.
Flea?
Actually, I'm reading it right now.
Yeah. It's, it's amazing.
I love it.
It's a beautiful book.
Yeah.
It's so strange and weird and.
I know.
Quirky and funny.
Yeah. It's good.
And the Hillel thing, when Hillel passed
and then John Frusciante became the guitarist,
and then he had his problems and was gone,
and in his absence,
I felt like the band never really could find its groove,
you know?
And having him back in the band is like a pretty cool thing.
I'll share one Red Hot Chili Pepper story.
Yeah.
So they played,
at Stanford, it must have been 1986.
I remember going to, going to a concert.
It was outdoors, at the outdoor amphitheater there,
and this was during the like Freaky Styley days.
Okay.
Like,
when they really were just like this party band,
like starting out,
and the concert was in the middle of the day
and there couldn't have been more than like,
maybe 200 people there,
like it wasn't a heavily attended thing,
it wasn't like a musty situation.
And it was in the era when they would play with the sock,
you know, basically naked with the socks on.
Yes.
You know.
And they're up there doing that.
Yes.
And I just remember Hank Wise,
my friend Hank wise, who I swam with at Stanford,
who is the guy who left the voicemail.
Yes.
We talked about it.
He has the record for fastest Catalina Channel swim.
Right.
He's probably, 52 now,
or something like that.
Amazing.
He's just a character and like a beautiful human being.
We gotta go swim.
I love, I love Hank.
Yeah.
We gotta go swim with him.
But Hank is an extreme extrovert
and Hank just got up on stage and put the sock on
and like danced and did the whole thing.
Like, I'll never forget that it was unbelievable,
but I would've not have thought at that time,
that they would become this like super band.
That's funny. I have a,
a story like that with Phish in 1991 in Vermont,
at like some gym, you know, like community college, gym.
I forget what it was, but yeah,
and you just never guess they'd,
they'd take the world by storm.
But you know, the sh, the show was phenomenal,
really, really great, but it wasn't cheap.
And I will say, like, back in the day,
you could go to a concert,
and you just buy the ticket face value,
and if you called early enough,
you'd be like right in the front row
for like 15, 20 bucks,
and now, like these, there are hundreds of dollars...
Right.
For a seat to get anywhere,
in that, in that stadium.
But that's, I guess the economy of things,
I mean, it, it does,
it does play into what we're gonna talk about later.
Like, it's, it's, I love to see these bands, you know,
getting paid and doing their thing.
Mm-hmm.
Very, very expensive now, to just go to a concert.
Back, back then, it was like,
it was normal to go to concerts.
Right. Yeah. You go to concerts all the time.
Right.
It wasn't, it,
it wasn't wasn't a situation
that would break your bank to go see a show.
No.
Yeah.
No
So that gets into the wealth inequality stuff
we'll talk about a little bit later.
But yeah, so that was great.
And, and SoFi is a beautiful place.
However, it's kind of like Orwellian, like,
you know how in Dodger Stadium, no matter where you are,
you know how to get to where you need to go,
cause there's signs everywhere
and you could figure out the system,
in SoFi, no matter where you are,
you have no idea where you are.
I haven't been there yet.
Yeah. Yeah. It's kind of an interesting.
Is that intentional?
I don't know. It's like a tech campus that like you go in,
but it was great, great show.
You guys should see the tour.
I'm hoping they come back through,
on the back end promoting the new album.
They've just released like two albums in six months, so.
Mm-hmm.
Yeah.
How's the fitness?
Fitness is good. You know,
I think I ticked it up a little bit.
I've been doing like 25 miles running
and three to four miles of swimming every week.
And so that kind of has,
I think I've, I've even lost a few pounds and,
and feeling a little bit,
I'm not fast, but I'm faster.
Yeah?
Yeah.
Good man.
Little bit.
You know, it's still...
From, from dad bod, to father figure.
(both laughing)
That's, I thought that's your secret?
Your next book?
No. That's pretty good.
I can't take credit for that.
I saw that on social media somewhere.
Oh, right.
Like somebody,
like it was a T-shirt or something like that,
but I thought that was pretty great.
It's okay.
Yeah.
Great writer still.
Speaking of which, we got shout out our boy, Dan Drake.
Oh yeah.
Creative director here at the RRP.
He just celebrated his one year anniversary of working here.
He moved his entire family from St. Louis to,
to participate in this show.
He's been an incredible value add to the team,
and over the course of the past year,
has lost 40 pounds.
It's amazing.
40 Pounds,
without really even trying by his words,
like he just went plant based,
because he was in this environment,
and the 40 pounds slowly melted away.
It's that amazing.
Yeah. It's pretty incredible.
So that's what happens when you embrace
this thing that we're doing.
That's what happens when you come here,
dad bod cannot exist in this environment.
No.
It melts.
From dad bod to father figure.
Another from dad bod to father figure.
Rich, let's let's cut the bullshit.
How the hell are you?
Well, Adam, in honor of this week's podcast guests,
Susan Cain.
Okay.
The queen of quiet,
the champion of introverts and all things melancholic,
I am here today to channel my inner introvert,
into a short burst of extra extroversion just for you.
(Adam laughing)
Yes.
Is that like a... ?
Do you know Susan Cain?
No.
She's great.
Yeah.
So you're not up.
You, you didn't listen to that podcast
that we just dropped this morning already.
Come on, man.
Oh, the one this morning?
You're a team member.
From this morning?
Yes.
Yeah.
You had a couple hours to listen to it...
That's a great one.
On your way over here.
That's a great one. I love that one.
Anyway, yeah. You know,
I've been spending most of my time, Adam,
unsubscribing from email newsletters.
(Adam laughing)
Is that a, is that a warning shot
to not launch a newsletter?
Here's the thing,
like, I realize that, somewhere on the internet,
you can find my email address.
Like it's not that hard.
Right.
And so, I receive like 200 emails a day,
95 to 98% of which are,
newsletters that I did not subscribe to.
Oh, wow.
Somehow I just get added to this.
And so, I'm in this war of attrition with, with,
it's not necessarily spam,
because it's not like, you know,
some, somebody trying to scam me outta my money
or anything like that,
just like newsletters I didn't subscribe to.
So literally I spend like 20,
I'm committed now,
to see how many I can unsubscribe from.
But I unsubscribe from like,
like anywhere from five to 20 every single day,
and it doesn't seem to make a difference,
coz the next day, there's a whole new...
Zombie newsletters.
On-slot of newsletters that I have to unsubscribe,
but there's something weirdly satisfying,
about just unsubscribing,
like methodically unsubscribing every single day.
The hidden battle.
That's my obsessive compulsive outlet.
The hidden battles we all fight.
Yeah.
You should revoke their, their newsletter licenses.
Can you do that?
Well, I'm always, then I feel guilty,
coz then you know like when you unsubscribe,
sometimes it says, "Why are you unsubscribing?"
And you have a choice of like,
you know, I usually just say,
"I never, I never signed up for this,"
but you always have the option to, you know, report them.
Right.
And then I'm like, should I report them?
I don't know.
No.
Like, they're just out there getting their hustle on.
Yeah.
It's okay.
Shows great concern into (indistinct).
I'm gonna report them.
Just unsubscribe.
Yeah.
Vote with your subscription.
Quietly, quietly unsubscribe.
The challenge becomes when you're getting a newsletter
from somebody who's a friend.
Yes.
Who's got a product.
Right.
Or something like,
and then you're like, should I unsubscribe?
Like, like I get it, I'm a fan, I like it,
but I don't need to get an email
every two or three days about this,
but then are they gonna know that I unsubscribed?
Is this gonna...
They'll know.
Be...
They will know.
Create a, create complexity in my relationship.
I once, I once,
had a little, you know,
thing back when I was a single man with a woman,
and it didn't work out,
and I kind of, I unfollowed, you know, as you do,
but this person did not unfollow.
And then she had a great business that I was a fan of,
and, and all of a sudden I'm getting,
and I got the newsletter,
but I didn't like being reminded,
coz it didn't work out in my favor in that particular time,
it was, worked out for my favor now,
but at the time, I was probably a little bit hurt.
And so I was like, you know,
I don't want this person's email,
but I thought, I didn't want her to see that.
I didn't know much about email subscriptions,
and I didn't want her to,
I didn't wanna hurt her.
(both laughing)
Yeah.
So I unsubscribed and then the next thing you know,
like I'm down like a couple of follows,
like the business unfollowed me,
she unfollowed me, so, they know.
Yeah.
They know.
You got weaponized.
(Adam laughing)
Yeah.
Meanwhile subscribe to our newsletter of course.
Yes.
Yes?
If you wanna be up to speed on all of our podcasts
that we're releasing and you know what,
if it's not providing value for you,
you can unsubscribe.
Yeah.
I don't check that, I won't even know, it's fine.
No, you definitely won't know.
No.
You're too busy.
And I can't,
I can't be unsubscribing from all these newsletters
and then be mad if someone unsubscribing.
Well, you're, you're, you're bigger than that.
You're not perusing the subscription list.
Yeah. Anyway, one of the reasons that,
that we haven't done this in a bit is I was overseas.
I had a speaking event in Europe,
which was really cool,
and then spent a little bit of time in, in, in London,
which was great.
Stayed at my buddy Sacha's flat
right on Portobello road, which was like...
Oh, killer.
Amazing.
Like right in the thick of it,
the weather was like perfect.
Over Notting Hill.
Yeah, exactly.
Yes.
Like right, If you've seen that movie,
like literally right in the middle of like,
where that whole thing took place.
Yes.
30 years ago,
when that movie came out,
and just got to enjoy myself,
see some friends, I did a couple podcasts.
I hooked up with John McEvoy for round two,
which is amazing.
And Tony Riddle, the barefoot ultra running...
Oh cool.
Phenomenon,
known as the natural life stylist.
That was great.
Those are old school audio only podcasts,
as is the one I did with, with Rick Rubin.
So you have those to look forward to,
old school style, no video, no nothing, you know,
all the noise from the street
and everything else that happens when you kind of, you know,
do the traveling stuff.
Bringing the kit with you.
But it was great to see them
and just be a tourist and, and enjoy London.
I just wanna thank everybody who like stopped me
and said, said hello.
Lots of podcast fans out there.
Lots of Skolnick fans.
Really?
Passing on there, passing on there.
Did you hit Ottolenghi?
Does Ottolenghi have enough vegan options?
Did you go?
No, I had most of my meals at a place called Farmacy.
Oh cool.
Which is a really beautiful,
amazing plant-based restaurant.
Farmacy with an F?
Farmacy with an F.
Okay.
Yes, of course.
That's that's like farm to table.
The owner, Camilla Al Fayed, who was outta town,
I was hoping to meet her, is the owner,
and has like apparently her own farm,
where they basically grow everything
that they serve in the restaurant.
Amazing.
All that kind of stuff.
Also happens to be the half sister of Dodi Fayed.
Oh really?
Which is interesting.
So there's a little, you know, kind of like...
Right.
UK, UK pedigree, built into the whole thing,
and they have this whole movement around
healthy eating and regenerative farming
and all that kind of stuff.
I love that.
So, that was,
that was like my spot.
And as I mentioned,
I stayed at my buddy Sacha's flat,
longtime listeners of the podcast will remember
a podcast that I did with Sacha,
Sacha Gervasi and Jamie Dornan, the movie star,
we did that, that was episode 398.
It was a while ago.
And that conversation was around
a movie that, that Sacha wrote and directed,
called My Dinner with Herve,
that stared Peter Dinklage, that was on HBO.
Sacha's a screenwriter and a director.
And the flat that I was staying in
is really like his office, not his home,
but he was out of town and I was able to stay there,
which was fantastic.
And the reason I bring that up is that,
I have a podcast with Sacha coming up,
that's going to release on the 26th of September.
And it's around a documentary
that Sacha made called Anvil: The Story of Anvil.
Did you ever see this documentary?
No, but I saw the, I saw your Twitter Thread about,
about it all.
Yeah. So this is what's cool.
So Anvil, is the story of this heavy metal band
that was on the precipice of breaking big
and then never really made it,
but influenced all of these huge bands
that became wildly successful.
Okay.
And yet they never gave up on their dream
and Sacha kind of caught up with them
in their late forties and they were still rocking out
and making albums every, you know, every year, whatever.
Yeah. Yeah.
But just playing pubs and working, you know,
blue collar jobs to pay the bills,
and he made this beautiful documentary about their,
you know, kind of, you know,
pursuit and their refusal to give up on their dream.
And it's, it's, it's, you know,
it's an Indie doc that he self-financed,
that ended up becoming one of,
it's considered one of the great
rock documentaries of all time.
Okay.
It's a real life spinal tap
and it's really beautifully rendered.
And it came out 13 years ago.
I did a thread about it on Twitter,
which you can see if you're watching, you know,
I'll, I'll link it up in the show notes,
but it's really a thread about
what it means to pursue like an audacious dream
and, and never give up.
And it's the story,
it's kind of the parallel story of this band Anvil
and Sacha's career as a writer and director.
Like I said, he, he self-financed this documentary 13,
he was making it like 15 years ago.
He premiered it at Sundance to great, you know,
reception and applause,
but no buyers wanted to distribute it.
And I think he might have had one deal on the table
that wasn't so great.
And he was like, "Fuck it.
I'm going to basically release it myself."
Which you know,
in, in film parlance means you're kind of DOA.
Like, if a distributor isn't gonna put it in theaters,
now it's different with streaming,
this is before streaming,
it was considered like a lunatic move,
like you're gonna pay to put it in the theaters? Like...
Right.
You know, if you do that,
maybe you window it for like, you know,
a couple screenings.
Right.
But it's too expensive.
And he was able to, you know,
kind of bankroll a little bit of a release,
and the movie went on to great acclaim.
Like, so by taking that risk,
it really established his career as a filmmaker
and the film Anvil, because it was successful,
gave this band, the career that they had always sought.
So they kind of both succeeded as a result of this,
but it was still a small movie.
I mean, people,
it's sort of unanimously beloved,
but it kind of came and went.
Right. It wasn't like Searching for Sugar Man
or anything like that.
Right.
But it, but it sort of prefaced
all of those movies like before Amy.
You know, before Sugar Man,
like there was Anvil.
Yeah.
And all, like the Rock n Roll community loves it.
Like there's tons of bands.
Sacha has a million stories of bands
that just play it on loop and their tour buses,
and you know, they just,
they just love the movie.
But the reason I'm bringing this up is that,
during the course of COVID during lockdown,
for some reason,
somehow Gen Z and millennials unearthed this movie
and discovered it
and started just passing it along to their friends.
Really?
And it became like a thing.
Yes.
Like Anvil became a thing.
It was discovered by this younger generation
and that kind of outpouring
of love and support for the movie,
suddenly like made it relevant again.
And this distributor called Utopia has stepped in
and they're now re-releasing Anvil this fall
in theaters across the country and overseas.
Like that never...
Amazing.
Ever happens.
I know.
Like an Indie movie from
a decade and a half ago,
is getting re-released in movie theaters,
when barely any movies end up in the movie theater anymore.
It's a really cool story.
Very cool.
So not only is Sacha one of my best friends
who opened up his home to me when I was in London,
I'm trying to help him celebrate the release of this movie,
which is coming out September 26th, I think, as I said.
Yeah, the week of the 26th,
and that's when this podcast with Sacha
and Lips and Robb from the movie, is going to release.
So I have two band members,
the two main guys from the band and Sacha, so.
Fantastic.
And it's just a,
you know, it's insanity.
All right.
These guys.
So you have that to look forward to.
I can't wait to listen.
And thank you Sacha for letting me stay.
Do they play? Do they play a number.
No, no, but, but they're, they're oddly,
particularly Lips,
you know, he's now like in his late fifties, I guess,
shouldn't, you know, like in an aging,
Toronto dwelling, heavy metal head banging rocker,
who's still wears exactly what he wore
when he was 22 years old, you know?
Of course. Of course.
With like the same T,
he wears the, his own band T-shirt,
and he is got the fanny pack,
and like the whole, and the hair and the whole thing,
but he's so charming and endearing
and he's sort of this,
he's the self-help guru, you didn't need, you, you knew.
Yeah.
Like he's got all this kind of like crazy wisdom.
Some.
So it was really fun.
Some identities will never perish.
Yeah. That's right, right?
So that's that.
A couple quick things.
I was in a Porsche commercial.
I saw that.
Yeah. Which was cool.
Where's that?
Check that out.
Look it up right there, like,
Listen to (indistinct)
I don't know if we can play this on YouTube
without getting into trouble,
but yeah, we don't have sounds anyway.
I show up like a minute into it.
Does that mean
you're gonna be driving an E Porsche?
I, I would, I would like to be driving an E Porsche.
I am not driving an E Porsche.
(Adam laughing)
They didn't sweeten the, the (indistinct).
It's just, it's literally just a photograph.
It's like, it shows up.
That photograph deserves an E Porsche.
That photograph was taken by David Zen.
Thank you, David. Anyway.
Look at you, out there with Hawking and...
Which is cool. Yeah, man. Good company.
Yeah, bro.
I don't know who that chess genius is.
And I wanted to thank everybody for the,
the outpouring of love around the Mike Fremont episode.
The centenarian slash.
Amazing.
Multiple Masters world record holder,
in, in, in all kinds of running affairs.
Like he, he,
I feel like the world fell in love with that guy.
Like, it's just a beautiful thing.
How could you not?
To see,
so many people excited
to hear from somebody who is 100 years old.
And, and like I said, in the intro to that episode,
like, I don't think we do a very good job
in Western society,
of, of, of celebrating our elders
and respecting the wisdom that they have to share.
And I feel like that podcast did,
it was like my small part in trying to rectify that.
And it was just cool that
people really cottoned on to him
and loved what he had to share.
And, you know, he's,
it's hard not to love him, you know, it's great.
It's what makes your podcast, what it is, you know,
like that you find these amazing people
and put them on here
and like get to hear from them.
And sometimes they have a following,
but sometimes they're just really interesting human beings
that have a lot to say and, and, and share.
Yeah.
Do you think the reason that we don't treat elders as well
is because when we were like six and seven,
our grandparents bored us
with really boring stories of the old days
that are actually not boring,
but we thought they were boring.
But do you, do you, but do you think that,
And then we hold it against the elders.
Do you think that our generation
was unique in that?
No.
Like that's,
historically probably always been the case, right?
But the, but, but you know, in, in earlier days,
like we kept our elders close.
That's true.
Like we lived in a village,
and they were always there,
and they helped with raising the kids,
and there was an intimacy to that relationship
that is now more rare than common.
You're saying they weren't chucked into the nursing home?
Exactly. Yeah. It's fucked up what we do here.
Yeah. It, it seems off.
Yeah.
Do you, do you wish you lived in a village?
You do?
I mean, when you think, like, when I think back,
like some of my,
my happiest kind of living circumstances were communal,
like being in a dorm in college,
or living in a house in college
with a whole bunch of friends.
Like, I don't know that I would want to do that now,
but there's something about like,
being part of a, a, a group, you know,
in a living situation that holds a lot of it.
A crew.
And I think it's deeply embedded in our, in our DNA.
And now we define success as cloistering ourself in a,
in a large home at the end of a cul-de-sac
and separating ourselves from each other.
That's exactly how I define success.
Right? That's how you're living.
(Adam laughing)
I'm, I'm a cloistered man.
Yes.
Well, you should tune into the Susan Cain episode.
I'm going to.
Learn about your introversion Adam.
I would, I would call you an, an,
an introvert who can be periodically extroverted.
You know, I used to be thought of as just pure extrovert,
but I think I've always been an extrovert with like,
this deep vein of introversion.
Yeah. Maybe it's the converse of, of me.
Yeah.
Like more extrovert,
but you can't be a writer or be in love with writing
without having a serious streak of introversion.
This, this, this,
this career has completely warped my personality.
I was a, I had a really winning,
bright, happy personality before,
and now I'm a cranky old fucker.
That happens.
I share that.
Can I just ask one thing before we get to the ne...
Yeah.
The, the break?
Cause we, it's not in our, this is something different.
It's not even on our run of show,
but I feel like we,
we should talk about Salman Rushdie,
in just, just two minutes at tops.
Before we do that,
okay, before we do that.
Yeah.
I just wanna, there was, there was,
on the Mike Fremont thing,
kinda wanna close that out.
Yeah.
Mike, there was a, there was a, a reel,
a video that I put up,
where I believe I like asked him what he ate,
and he kind of said,
I eat, you know, like a whole fruit plant based diet.
And there were a lot of comments, like, like,
"Well, tell us what you actually eat, right?"
And in the longer podcast he goes into some detail,
but he only gave like one or two examples.
So, I think he had self-awareness
around not fully answering that question,
and he sent me an email saying,
"Here's, here's a full, like, picture of what I eat."
And so I copied that email
and I created a Google doc out of it,
that gives, you know, a pretty robust rundown of like...
Amazing.
The Mike Fremont diet.
So I'll link that up in the show notes.
I'm not gonna read it,
but it's like two pages long
of like various meals that he enjoys.
So, if you want to get on board,
on the Mike Fremont diet, hit that link.
Be like Mike.
And you'll find it there, be...
Yeah. Be like Mike.
Be like Mike.
Right?
Mikey, he likes it.
Mikey likes it.
All right. Salman.
Yeah. Salman Rushdie.
Obviously the tragedy happened,
he was attacked.
Yeah.
Fatwas apparently never go away,
and he was attacked by a crazy person
driven by, you know, I guess...
Extremist ideas.
Extremist, extremist, but extremist religious ideas,
and, and he survived, so...
Mm-hmm. There was a moment there
where it looked pretty dire,
like he wasn't going to survive.
Right. So the person who did that failed,
let's put that out there,
failed at the job, which is great,
but also because he's so strong.
But anyway, I just thought you, you know,
being an intellectual like yourself,
you might have some thoughts on Salman and (indistinct).
Yeah. I mean, it's, it's interesting.
It's been 30 years of fatwa on him, right?
And it took that long for this to catch up to him,
but that fatwa, you know,
in the minds of someone who inhabits that, you know,
religious, that level of religious zealotry,
has never wavered, right?
And so finally it occurred and it's shocking,
but also we shouldn't be surprised,
like this is the modus operandi of, you know,
a certain way of seeing the world that is, you know,
antithetical to our, you know, liberal democratic,
you know, perspective.
So it's shocking, you know, it's shocking.
It's also something that I think all writers,
or people who are participating in public discourse,
need to take note of,
especially as the world, you know,
seems at least from my perspective,
to be descending into a certain level of, of dissonance
and, and, and chaos,
that I don't remember, you know, in my lifetime.
Yeah.
And it's disturbing.
Yeah. The, the zealotry that is going on, you know,
obviously when it comes to this kind of thing,
it's, it's real life and death stuff,
but then there's also the zealotry
of controlling women's bodies.
And then we also have this increasing zealotry
of political ideology, which is not the same,
but it's still there.
And so liberalism is about
being able to express everything, right?
And, and so we have to check ourselves against this,
zealotry and the beliefs we hold so strongly,
and we can't let these
beliefs necessarily define our worldview,
because when you do
and you become more and more myopic,
then you just go into this funnel
that can lead to a pretty dark place, so yeah.
Yeah. Well, those funnels seem to be tightening.
They do.
These days.
And there's more of them.
Yeah.
But good for, you know, Salman Rushdie for, I mean,
he survived it, man.
Yeah.
What a bull and, and so I wish him well.
Yeah. Wishing him well.
All right. Let's take a quick break
and we'll be back with more
from Mr. Adam Skolnick and myself.
(gust of wind blows)
Sorry to interrupt the flow,
we'll be right back with more awesome,
but I wanna snag a moment
to talk to you about the importance of nutrition.
The thing is, most people I know,
actually already know how to eat better
and aspire to incorporate more whole plants,
more fruits, vegetables, seeds, beans, and legumes,
into their daily routine.
Sadly, however, without the kitchen tools and support,
very few end up sticking with it.
So, because adopting a plant-based diet
transformed my life so profoundly,
and because I want everybody to experience
some version of what I've experienced,
we decided to tackle and solve this very common problem.
The solution we've devised, I'm proud to say,
is The Plantpower Meal Planner,
our affordable all in one digital platform,
that sets you up for nutrition excellence
by providing access to thousands of highly customizable,
super delicious, and easy to prepare plant-based recipes.
Everything integrates with automatic grocery delivery
and you get access to our amazing team of nutrition coaches,
seven days a week, and many other features.
To learn more and to sign up,
visit meals.richroll.com,
and right now, for a limited time,
we're offering $10 off in the annual membership,
when you use the promo code RRHEALTH at checkout.
this is life-changing stuff people,
for just $1.70 a week,
literally the price of a cup of coffee.
Again, that's meals.richroll.com,
promo code RRHEALTH for $10 off in annual membership.
All right, let's get back to the show.
You know, we were just talking in the break,
but Salman Rushdie's attack was not the first time, right?
The, the Japanese translator of Satanic Verses was killed.
The Italian translator was attacked and survived.
The Norwegian publisher was attacked,
shot three times I believe, survived.
Eight, I think seven, eight, nine people were,
died in protests around Satanic Verses,
so when you see all of that, you gotta wonder, like,
you know, obviously it's it,
you can't hold the writer responsible, that's crazy,
but like you do wonder, like, how does that weigh, like,
what do you think about that?
Like writing something that, that,
leads to so much of that.
It's, I can't even imagine what that feels like.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah. I mean, it's quite treacherous.
And I feel like the, the, the threat level, like,
you know, has reached a different DEFCON,
than, than in past years.
Like everything just feels very heightened and, you know,
there is fear around, can I say this?
What will happen if I say this?
And it's a weird horseshoe politics thing,
because I think that applies on,
on both sides of the political spectrum.
100%.
Obviously, you know,
the left historically being the champions of free speech,
and now the left, you know,
being in favor of certain curtailing of free speech
and the right, you know,
shouting for broader free speech protections.
It's just a very strange time.
Except when it comes to...
Except when it comes to what you teach kids in schools.
Right. Then, then yeah.
Bring it all in.
Right.
Right? You know what I mean?
Like, like when, when Mar-a-Lago was, you know,
when the search warrant was, was executed on Mar-a-Lago,
it's like, ban the FBI, except.
Yeah. Defund the FBI.
Except when it comes to trans issues,
like seek the FBI on them.
Right.
You know, it's, it's.
I'll tell you, you know...
It's, it's issue specific.
When those agents showed up at Mar-a-Lago,
and ruined our perfect morning out on the links,
it was, it was treacherous man.
I can't imagine like how they would go into such a, I mean,
it was such a perfect day at Mar-a-Lago until that moment,
you know?
Right. I know.
Yeah.
And listen, Adam.
What?
I know there's great temptation
to go down the Mar-a-Lago, Donald Trump...
Oh, right.
Or Alex Jones trial rabbit hole.
There's a lot of delicious schadenfreude to be, you know,
enjoyed with all of that.
Yeah.
But let me tell you something,
I heard something from a writer you might have heard of
called Yuval Noah Harari.
Oh yes.
Yes.
I heard him speak and he said something that,
that really has stuck with me.
And I, I actually have been thinking about it
every single day.
He said, don't be a profiteer in the cultured war.
Yeah.
In other words,
in other words, like don't,
don't be a content creator who is trying to monetize strife.
Right.
Or be a participant in, you know,
this, this kind of ongoing
battle for hearts and minds.
I think it there's, there's a distinction here,
because obviously if you have a platform,
and you feel strongly about
using that platform to speak your truth,
you should do that,
but that's different from knowing how to activate people,
and antagonize them,
and, and, and, and doing it from, you know,
from a motivation place of, of profiting, you know?
Yeah. I agree with him and I respect that.
However, it sounds like
he's never brunched with Alex Jones over at Mar-a-Lago,
and that is a wonderful experience,
let me tell you.
That, talk about a brunch,
you know what I mean?
Do you think that,
that brunch would exceed the experience of
sitting down for brunch with Alex Jones
and enjoying however many...
Alex Jones?
Bloody, bloody Marys he might enjoy?
(Adam laughing)
You know, I wasn't.
But we're not gonna go there.
I wasn't a guest.
We're not going there.
I just wanna say, I wasn't guest.
This is endurance corner.
I Wasn't a guest at Mar-a-Lago,
I was just there to scoop ice cream.
Sometimes you take outta town jobs in this business.
That that guy opened up a, a, a,
an ice cream place in Manhattan.
Did he?
Yeah, it's called catchin...
I forget what it's called.
What's the guy's name again?
He's friends with Joanne Molinaro, the Korean vegan.
She went there for the opening.
So it's nice that he,
he took his ice cream fame on TikTok
and translated it into a storefront.
Brick and mortar?
Yeah. Brick and mortar, going, going reverse.
Let's get him on the pod.
He would be good actually.
I know he listens.
Now, I feel bad that I don't remember his name.
I'm with you in the,
don't, don't fetch the low hanging fruit
of the culture wars.
Yeah.
Nobody needs us to do that.
Come on man.
No, I, I really don't want to be a muckraker in that arena.
No, but can we joke about it though?
Yeah, of course.
Okay.
We always can.
All right.
But we're here today, Adam.
Yeah.
To talk obscure endurance sports.
That's what we live for here.
(both laughing)
I know right?
This is the sports news you didn't need.
I feel like, yeah.
We're not participating in the culture war,
but what we are doing
is forcing down people's throats,
a lot of people's throats.
Yeah.
Tiny sports that most people don't care about.
Yeah. These are the sports.
This is the sports cast you never wanted.
Right.
(laughing)
Ready? Let's start.
Rich, throw it over to you.
(laughing)
Well, we're gonna start with one of the larger sports.
We're gonna start with swimming,
a sport close to my heart, Adam.
Yeah.
Because a young man from Romania, called David Popovici,
at all of 17 years old,
broke the world record in the 100 freestyle,
on going going 46:86 at the European championships.
Crazy, crazy.
He's the youngest 100 meter freestyle world record holder.
There's lots of videos on the internet of, you know,
this race, if you're on swimming Twitter, which I am.
Yeah.
Of course everybody is, right?
I, I follow that guy that you love so much.
You know, like, his underwater form,
is like the, the most beautiful, unbelievable thing ever.
I just pulled up a video of him like swimming.
It's like...
look at that.
This is perfect form.
Yeah.
But to be 17 years old,
and break that world record,
coz if you're, this is the thing,
and I talked about this with, with Malcolm Gladwell,
like, if you're that young,
how many years of hardcore training
do you have under your belt?
Right.
Not very many.
No.
Right?
So, how is he going so much faster
than anyone ever has before at such a young age?
What do you think the answer is?
I think it's, I think it's like the,
the advance of the human species.
Okay
Like this is how world records go, right?
Yeah.
Like,
obviously there's advances in training and nutrition
and, and the, and recovery and the like...
Right.
That inform all of this,
but you know, it's just cool that,
when you think a world record will never get broken
or there's some ceiling or bar,
that would prevent, you know,
a human from ever doing a certain thing
and then they do it,
we're all kind of uplifted.
And a good looking kid too.
Super good looking kid,
obviously, you know, a huge, bright new star.
yeah.
In swimming and...
and we need that.
Can't wait to see what this kid does. I mean...
Like is there, because after, I mean,
we have Dressel and we have Katie.
Right, but Dressel is, you know, in the Twilight...
Right.
Of his swimming career.
And he just did something and in a 25 meter pool
at like the NCAA's or something,
and he broke some hallowed record.
Was that the 200 or the 150?
I can't remember.
I mean, he's broken so many records.
Yeah.
What's really cool,
is they just did this thing called dual in the pool
that they do, I don't know how, what the,
how often they host it, but it's a dual meet
between Australia and the United States,
and they do all these wacky events.
Right.
And they fire off like,
flame plumes and they try to make it into like a spectacle,
and they did this like a 200 IM event,
but you got to choose the order of strokes.
Oh really?
So like they dive in and one guy's swimming backstroke
and one guy's swimming freestyle,
and one guy's swimming butterfly.
So they separate dramatically over the course of 200 meters,
and then, you know,
the guy who's like finishing with breaststroke
against the guy who's finishing with freestyle,
who's 15 meters behind him,
like, is he gonna catch him?
You know?
What would your,
what would your order be?
I mean, that, that also goes to the Malcolm Gladwell thing
of like, how do you make these more obscure sports,
more interesting to a mainstream audience.
And I think being creative
and like letting go of tradition a little bit and, you know,
experimenting with some of that stuff is fun and cool.
Would you have a, would you do the different order?
Would you, it's usually backstroke first, right?
It's usually...
No, it's fly, back...
It's fly, back...
Breast, free.
Okay.
Yeah.
And they do like really short races
and, you know, you know, I mean,
just stuff that's like fun.
We could talk about that more, but that's a whole,
we have too many other things to talk about.
Let's keep going.
I mean, Popovici also set the world junior record
in the 200 freestyle
with the fastest textile swim in history.
It was the third fastest
or fourth fastest performance of all time,
third fastest performer of all time.
So, clearly a star in the making.
Yeah.
But,
this concludes swimming news for ROLL ON episode 700.
Yeah. Let's move over to Death Valley.
Death Valley...
Back to you Rich.
Well, we do have a little bit of a, a,
an update on the Badwater situation
that we talked about last time.
Yes.
There was some controversy over the women's victor,
Ashley Paulson.
There were some people who were skeptical that
she actually won the race,
or there might have been some shenanigans,
if you want to hear us discuss that,
go back and listen to that,
but I thought it would be the responsible thing
to kind of update everybody on, on what's transpired there.
The initial post by marathon investigation
that was really questioning the veracity of the result,
has done an exhaustive analysis
and ended up publishing a,
another post on this that goes into extreme detail,
like analyzing her garment data and, you know,
comparing her performance to past other performers,
and, you know, looking at GPX files, and graphs,
and course on course, you know,
talking to people who were on course, et cetera,
and basically concluded, you know,
this post goes on and on and on forever,
we'll link it up in the show notes,
but basically ends up saying that her,
he, he can't help but conclude that her result is legit.
So I just wanted to point that out.
Okay.
There's another guy who on his subs stack
is not having it.
I'll link that up as well.
Some guy named Kevin Beck wrote a long post about,
basically saying that he doesn't believe that she did it,
but look, the marathon investigator guy, you know,
he really spent a lot of time looking at this
and towards that, and Chris Kostman,
who's the race director of Badwater wrote a long post
basically saying she earned this victory
and he explains why,
and he also highlights
a lot of other outstanding performances
that sort of came outta the blue,
which is part of the dispute around Ashley.
And he includes two of David Goggins' performance,
it's like the first time that he did it,
kind of coming out of nowhere as a bigger guy
and actually, you know,
really distinguishing himself,
and then coming back with a huge improvement
on the year before, and basically says,
this is, there is historical precedent for this, so anyway.
Well, if Kostman says so, I believe him.
Chris Kostman, I mean, he's run that race forever
and has been...
He's the law on Badwater.
Yeah. And while we're, you know,
talking about 130 mile races on, on, on tarmac,
we gotta, we gotta, we gotta talk about Oz.
Oz Pearlman.
Back in the news again,
friend of the pod.
Back in it.
He, he came on the pod because of Adam.
Adam is, you know, the contact point there,
the connective tissue.
Oz not only is this unbelievable mentalist,
he broke Robbie Balenger Central Park record.
We talked about that before,
and then must have been two weeks ago, I think,
he, he did this extraordinary challenge
where he ran 130 plus miles from Montauk,
the very tip of Long Island,
like out past the Hamptons,
all the way to Manhattan,
130 miles.
Times Square.
On city streets to Times Square,
and he did it in 21 hours.
Unbelievable.
Which is crazy.
Crazy.
Including throwing down like six minute plus pace
during the last five or 10 K.
Yeah.
And running a five, I think he ran a 5:56 final mile.
Yes. He call...
That guy's a freak.
He's a freak. I, he called me, I think,
miles 70 ish or something,
I talked to him during
and he had just come through a hellish period,
cause it was hot.
It was like the hottest day of the year.
He also did it, you know, hottest,
hottest most humid day of the year.
I know.
And so...
And it's just pavement, like the oppressive humidity.
Yeah. And he made it, you know,
he said there were some darker moments.
This was harder obviously than the Central Park thing.
And there were dark, even, you know,
there were darker moments.
I mean, it was mostly coz of the weather I think.
And he, you know, he definitely...
He dug a hole, but then he crawled out of it.
He, he went, he, he saw the darkness.
Mm-hmm. Yeah. Which is unusual coz he,
it all seems like a breeze with him.
Yeah.
For some reason.
Well cause he goes hard too. He goes quick, you know,
he goes quick, but he was able to keep going and,
and killed it once he got into Manhattan.
And, and then I think as in true Oz form,
got on a plane the next day,
and then he flew to Tampa Bay to like,
entertain the Tampa Bay Bucks
Yeah.
And hang out with Tom Brady.
Yeah. He's with Tom Brady the day after.
I mean after the Central Park thing,
he went directly Augusta.
Damascus.
Damascus. Yeah, yeah, yeah. Yeah.
(both laughing)
I spoke to Robbie Balenger about it briefly and he,
you know, he loves Oz.
He was, you know, he's so impressed with, you know,
how much faster Oz ran the Central Park thing
than, than he did.
And he pointed out aply that,
that Oz is a guy who, although he has,
you know, quite a profile as a mentalist,
is sort of like not given his due
in the ultra running community.
Like they're not...
Really?
Well, when you think of the great ultra runners,
like he doesn't come to mind.
Right.
But his performances are, you know, unbelievable.
Yeah.
And so the hope with this, you know,
Montauk to Manhattan thing
was that that would put him on the map
in a new and interesting way.
And, and, you know, Robbie wanted to help do that.
So he, Robbie and, and Reese Robinson,
who used to work for me as a content creator
have created this thing called the Audacious Report,
which is a YouTube channel,
that is making really high end documentaries,
or mini documentaries about athletes and races
in the ultra running world.
So they chronicled Oz's,
Oz's, Montauk to Manhattan thing,
and I'm sure they're editing together something amazing.
They shared it, you know,
you should follow Audacious Report on Instagram,
if you're interested in this stuff,
coz like their Instagram stories,
like, you can follow these things in real time.
That's how I followed the Oz run.
Yeah. me too.
Yeah. Yeah.
Me too.
Yeah. And I think they were in Leadville just recently.
Yeah, which brings us to Leadville,
because they went there to Chronicle Hellah,
our boy Hellah Sidibe.
Yeah.
Running, not only running Leadville for the first time,
as far as I know, it's his first,
even though he is run across the country,
First time he's done that.
First, first black person to do that,
he had never really done a, a race, like, an ultra...
Any race?
Any ultra race.
So he'd done 10 K's or marathons.
I'm sure he had. You know, I'm sure he's,
yeah, I think he's done a lot of that, that kind of stuff,
but I don't think he's, you know, entered a formal ultra.
Right.
And, and really doesn't have
much experience on trails, period.
Like he lives in New Jersey and runs city streets and...
Right.
Relatively flat terrain,
but he put Leadville on the calendar.
He went out early to spend time with Robbie.
They like, he was like living with him, I think,
and Robbie lives in a small Colorado town.
And they went up to Leadville for like a training camp,
so he could recon the course and all of that.
And he did good, our boy did pretty good.
He ran Leadville in 27:44.
Amazing.
He was the 146 finisher overall, the 118th male.
He was 41st in the 30 to 39 age group.
So it's not like, oh, he just went out and, and won it.
No.
But I was very interested to see how he was gonna do,
coz when you see, you know, him running, you know,
on his Instagram or whatever,
he has this incredibly beautiful,
oh yeah.
Long stride.
He looks like a, a gazelle, like a, you know,
a track and field athlete.
That's what a runner should look like.
I think, when I see that.
Yes.
But that's not how races like,
that's not how races like Leadville go, go.
It's like, what's gonna happen?
Like yes, he ran across the United States.
You're saying, you don't wanna lift...
He's clearly an unbelievable athlete.
You don't necessarily wanna have
the high stride as much, right?
Well, there's a lot of walking and climbing and you know,
and it's a cold, different kind of thing, you know?
So, it was, in my mind it was like,
he's either gonna absolutely destroy and crush it,
or he is gonna not finish.
And so I think he seems like he ran a really smart race
and I'm sure a lot of that
had to do with Robbie's Sage council.
Right.
And interestingly,
he, he beat Harvey Lewis by like an hour.
Our boy Harvey who is a, you know,
an unbelievably successful elite ultra, you know,
distance competitor.
But I would say, look, Harvey runs, he,
Harvey does so many races, you know?
Yeah.
Like guy's like doing 100 mile races,
like almost every weekend or every other weekend,
you know, what would've happened
if Harvey made Leadville his number one priority
and focused on that?
Probably would've been a bit of a different thing,
but you know, for context,
Hellah being, you know, in his very first ultra and,
and you know, besting Harvey is, is like no small thing.
So congrats to both of them,
love the both you guys.
And just also for context,
the winner, Adrian McDonald,
did it in 16 hours in five minutes,
which is unbelievable.
It's gotta be a record, right?
Is that a long run record?
I don't, I don't think it is.
I don't know. I should probably know that,
but I, I don't think it's a record, but...
It's a crazy time.
16 Hours?
You have to do this hope pass climb.
I mean, you're going up to 12,900 feet, it's,
It's between 10 and 12,5, right? So Like it's.
And it was like raining at one point it's cold. Ugh.
Unbelievable.
And shout out to Clare Gallagher, the women's winner,
who completed it in 19 hours and 37 minutes.
Also Mental.
But basically. Yeah.
Like, just eight hours faster than Hellah.
Right?
Yeah. (laughing) Right?
Insane. Yeah. She's a very gifted athlete as well.
I mean, Adrian McDonald,
going 11 hours faster than Hellah.
Right. Well, some of these, I mean, I would,
I wonder where Adrian is based.
Clare's based in Boulder, you know, like she, like a lot,
I would imagine a lot of the like top ultra people.
They live it altitude.
They live at altitude.
They live in the mountains.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. They don't live in a New Jersey suburb.
No.
Yeah.
Anyway, you can find all the results at, at, at Athlinks.
If you're watching on video,
you can see what it looks like here.
We'll link that up in the show notes,
if you wanna check that out.
And, and it would be interesting to see if Hellah...
And look forward to the Audacious Report...
Yeah.
Documentary that is hopefully to come.
And I, I I'm interested to see
if Hellah does more of these.
He looked, he looked pretty stoked.
He looked great at the end.
Yeah. I know. Well, he does that.
He does his thing.
His trademark.
I love it.
You know, what do you call that?
I don't know.
Jason did you do that?
The bird flying..
At the end of one of your runs?
Yeah.
No way.
(laughing)
Jason doesn't do that.
Well, we should shout out Blake
who just ran the bulldog 50K.
Did he?
This past weekend.
Yeah, man.
I missed that.
I know, see?
Blake?
All these runners, losing weight,
eating plant based.
I know.
Conquering ultras.
I'm not even...
Get on board bro.
I won't even be able to get
a rolling nomination next year.
I'm just trying to get my back sorted so I can join them.
It sounds like you were running,
it looked like you were running recently.
A little bit. Yeah.
Like I'm, my back is relatively stable.
I'm not pain free
and I'm just testing it out with some really light zone one,
kind of walk, jog, hike.
Nice.
kind of things.
I did, I, I, I started that when I was in London.
I would just go out in the morning
and spend three hours kind of walking a little bit.
Then I would jog a little bit,
Then I'd walk and just,
I just wanted to see how the back would hold up
and it didn't seem to exacerbate it.
It's not like, "Oh, it's gone,"
and I can, I have a green light to just go full bore.
So, I'm being very gentle on myself,
but for my mental health,
just to get out and elevate my heart rate a little bit
has been nice, so.
That's great, man. Happy to hear that.
Back to the mountains we got UTMB.
Yup.
Which starts today.
So we're recording this on Monday, August 22nd.
It's a whole week of races,
it's not just one race.
I know John McEvoy, he just texted me some images.
He did one of the races.
I think maybe the 40K, I'm not sure,
but the big one is coming up this weekend.
It's gonna be an interesting showdown.
I think that there's a really good chance that
some American women can distinguish 'EM,
distinguish themselves this year.
I think the, the race to watch on the men's side
is going to be Jim Walmsley,
who moved to France to train with Franco Den,
who I also did a podcast with that's coming up soon.
Jim has had trouble cracking this race.
I think this will be his fourth attempt.
He's never won it.
This year, he forewent the Western States 100,
to really just focus on this race,
kind of the way Lance Armstrong was the first to
really focus on the Tour de France.
Right.
Like he didn't do all,
he like opted out of a lot of the other races,
just so he could, he was like,
"This is the one that matters."
I think it's interesting that,
that Jim is having that approach to UTMB.
And this is ultra-trail?
With his goal being the first Mont-Blanc.
Mont-Blanc.
Yeah.
And so is this considered...?
It's the most prestigious kind of,
celebrated ultra trail race in the world.
In the world, it's above Leadville?
Like the spectators come out,
it's like an insane media circus.
It's like a really big deal.
It's the Boston marathon of ultra.
And no American has ever won it.
Okay.
So that's what everyone's gonna be looking for.
But he's gotta go up
against Kílian, and there's some other,
you know, interesting competitors,
so we'll see what happens.
Kílian's gonna be there?
Kílian's gonna be there, Shad Kennedy.
Is he a past champion?
Kílian has won it. Yeah.
I don't, I don't even know how many times,
won it a bunch, three or four times.
Camille Herron is doing it, so that'll be cool.
Friend of the pod,
and stay tuned, we'll report back on that.
But from the mountains to the sea we go.
From the mountains to the sea.
My Vertical Blue friend.
There was Vertical Blue.
For those unfamiliar,
Yes there was.
The quote, unquote, am I quoting myself?
The Wimbledon of free diving?
I don't know.
It now has been said by so many people
in so many different publications.
I can't even remember it.
Leah Barrett, the great photographer,
I think, defined it that way to me way back when,
and I stole it from her and put it in print.
Mm. You plagiarizing bastard.
It's not plagiarizing. It's, you know,
it's a, what's it called? It's a.
License.
Yeah.
It's a.
License,
An owed.
Not owed.
So this year, this year, the big performances.
So just to, to open it up,
there are four disciplines that people compete in,
there's constant weight, which is with the monofin.
Hold on one second.
Yeah.
Let me just say...
Here we are back talking about free diving again.
I know.
I just have to call it out.
As much as I,
try to escape this like,
strange world that no one cares about.
Yeah.
Here we are again.
I specialize in strange worlds that no one cares about.
We should get,
is there like a governing body to free diving?
There is. I'm gonna talk about that.
They should be paying us for all this promotion.
After what I have to say, they might not want to.
Okay, go ahead.
(Adam laughing)
But let's start with the good,
basically just to break it down,
there are four disciplines.
There's constant weights.
Keep it brief though.
That's where the monofin,
there's free immersion
where you pull yourself down a rope and back.
Again, all on one breath.
There's the constant, no fins.
That means they're just doing a breaststroke down,
basically a modified breaststroke and back.
And then there is constant weight bifins.
Just like tip,
like you see Orlando in this photograph right here.
It's the long bifins, you see spear fishermen wearing.
Really flexible.
Yeah, very flexible.
Individual foot...
Exactly.
Not a monofin.
And they are they're tethered to align.
They swim down on one breath,
grab a, grab a tag and bring it up,
and then once they get to the surface,
they have to prove that they're with it,
and there's a surface protocol involved.
And if they are,
they get a white card, they get points,
they get credit for, if it's a record.
There were two men's world records at this event.
One was 127 meter free immersion dive
from Mateusz Malina from Poland,
who I've seen dive once before and a mega performance.
He had tried it once.
He tried it twice.
The first attempt he did not make it.
The second he turned early,
the second attempt he did make it.
And then there was 120 meters from Arnaud Jerald,
he is a 26 year old young stud.
I think he's the most exciting young athlete
on the men's side that we've seen
in quite some time in this sport,
so it's pretty great
because he did something that we had never seen with bifins.
When, when I first started,
bifins weren't even a category,
when I was kind of cataloging all this for one breath.
But at the, at that time,
I don't think people even got to 100 meters in bifins,
because you know, scissor kicking especially,
you can't even do it really, that,
that efficiently.
Right.
Most people who compete even with bifins
are doing a dolphin kick.
Dolphin is a way more efficient.
This guy kicks scissor kicks back from depth.
Hmm.
It's amazing.
I, I put a video.
Going down though, does he?
NPR has a video.
I didn't see the first 20 meters.
By the time I saw a video,
he was already free falling, in the video I saw,
I sent you an NPR clip
that they put it on their Instagram of Arnaud Jerald.
And I spoke with him and he is just really a delightful guy.
He grew up spear fishing in France,
and, and, and just fell in love with going deep,
and he always used bifins.
It was like second nature for him.
And so for the last five years,
he's been able to have sponsors and compete
and just focus as a professional athlete.
And he is going to start looking at the monofin,
because, I mean, if you're doing 1:20 in bifins,
what's your potential with a monofin?
Remember the record is 130 meters.
So, that's Alexey's world record,
and Alexey wasn't there,
and that brings us to ADA.
He was banned from Vertical Blue,
it's called the Wimbledon of free diving
and they took it Literally.
ADA is the governing body?
ADA is the governor body of,
there's two competing ones,
but for this,
ADA is the governing body,
and they took that Wimbledon for free diving literally
and banned Russians.
Wouldn't let Russians compete,
as if Vladimir Putin has any idea
what Vertical Blue or ADA is.
And so Alexey who has,
obviously is not in favor of any of this,
is, was banned.
And it's unfortunate,
because then he would've had a chance
to have records broken back.
Speaking to Alexey,
he's highly confident he could,
he's going to take both records back when he's allowed to,
he's hoping to get a pass from ADA
to compete in the next competition coming up.
He's training right now in, in Kaş, Turkey.
And he's told me that, he, his,
what he thinks the human limit is on these dives,
people aren't even scratching yet.
He says he has a lot left in him
and is, is, is eager to do it,
but he also was of good spirits.
He's he, you know,
Arnaud is one of the Molchanov athletes,
he loves Arnaud and was really happy for him.
And so, like he's just,
the way he talked about it, it was amazing.
So it's unfortunate,
I think for Vertical Blue and for ADA,
that, that they would ban their best athlete.
It just seems,
especially when they're trying to sell,
like pay per view,
to get to see the dive eye
and you don't have your best athlete there.
It just, it, it, it, it struck me as a,
kind of the wrong choice.
On the women's side,
Alenka Artnik is the deepest woman ever on constant weight,
and she had hit 120, 125 meters in training,
and that would be a new world record.
She attempted 123 meters. I think her record is 122,
she attempted 123 meters on her first dive
and didn't make it.
In fact, I think she blacked out,
it was her first blackout in competition,
she never had that before.
Her second dive, she dialed it back,
hit 111 meters comfortably.
Good enough to win that discipline,
but that was the only white card dive she did.
She kind of hinted at burnout on her Instagram
and it's taken a step back.
And it just shows you that like,
this obsession compulsion to keep going and keep going,
it can, it can bite back at you,
which I've heard of from other athletes.
So, you know, obviously I'm a huge, huge fan,
and respect Alenka a lot,
so I'm hoping that, you know,
everything's good and she's back out there.
Fatima Korok of Hungary won the overall for women,
and, and that's it.
I wanna shout out also to my pal,
great free diver from Japan named Tetsuo Hara,
who is more of our gen.
And he, I've been, you know,
he's been at every competition I've, I've been at, I think.
Every time I've been to Vertical Blue, he's been there,
and he's come and dove with us at Doom a couple of times,
and he hit 96 meters, his personal best,
So that's, that's pretty cool.
Wow.
And so that's, that.
Congrats also to Will Trubridge on another great event,
you know, I really hope to get back to Long Island one day
and see these guys compete.
It's fun to see Orlando Bloom there.
Pretty cool.
Yeah. So, so that's, you know,
what caught my attention is Orlando Bloom's Instagram post.
Yeah.
Where he is this gorgeous photograph of him,
that's him right there with the bifins, is it not?
Yeah. And he got on the line.
I think he did, you know,
there, there's opener dives, and they have whoever,
like, they kind of give that out to tribute.
So like kind of the first pitch.
And so I don't know if he did an opener dive,
I think he did,
and so I don't know how deep went,
but he got on the line and did a dive.
Yeah, he was, I think he was there Camila Jaber, Jaber.
I don't, it might be Jaber, she's from Mexico.
She did some national records,
and, and she works as stunt doubling in film business,
so it seems like...
Right.
He was there to see her swimming
so that maybe they've crossed paths, so.
Look at this insane video of her.
Yeah. She's phenomenal.
She's beautiful.
And so Alexey's world record is 130.
130 Meters with constant weight, and he had,
I think it was 126 meters in free immersion and...
I mean, just imagine that.
Yeah.
That's, and then you gotta go back, right?
So double that.
Right.
And now imagine basically swimming that distance in a pool
without taking a breath.
Well there's.
So swimming 260 meters.
That, that isn't even accounting for, you know,
all of the pressure and all of that kind of stuff.
Yeah.
Like it's unbelievable.
Dynamic is what you're talking about.
And I, I'd have to look what the world record is,
in dynamic and that's going back and forth.
And it, though it looks like the world record for dynamic
is almost 300 meters, let me see.
Yeah. 300 meters and that's Mateusz as well, Malina.
So he has that.
So that's 300 meters in a pool,
back and forth, back and forth.
Unbelievable.
One breath.
I know. Wonderful.
Yeah. They're, I mean,
they're holding their breath for like four minutes,
you know, and swimming,
and the, the, the record for,
but right now, talking to Alexey,
he thinks like the record,
like he thinks the human limit for constant weights,
is like 150 meters, that's what he thinks.
Right.
Something close to that.
And he's, he's brewing up a special, special event
that I won't leak now.
And hopefully it, it comes to fruition,
but it's another big spectacle.
So he's, I think he took it personally
and he is thinking of different ways
of, of, of coming back to it,
but at the same time he took it lightly,
so it's both at the same time.
So, you know, I just think anytime,
I, I thought the same thing with Wimbledon,
I think to hold Russian athletes accountable,
for the, to the, for the decisions
of very few people in government,
in this case, one person who is obviously seems bent,
is just silly.
It doesn't make any sense to me and...
Yeah, that's another thing
that, that we talked about with, with Malcolm Gladwell.
Yeah.
Coz his whole legacy of speed thing
is all about like the,
the intersection of sport and activism
and the role of the athlete at the Olympiad.
And you know,
the conclusion when you kind of look down through history
is that these bans are really ineffective.
They might be, you know, motivated by good concerns.
Sure.
But they're not actually doing anything,
like actually allowing the athletes
who are victims in all of this to compete
and perhaps providing an opportunity,
for the athletes to have the ability to be activists,
should they choose to,
is a better route towards addressing that concern.
Agreed. You know, banning,
Medvedev I think was the world number one at the time
from Wimbledon and, and like, that's,
like, he's not Djokovic.
We're ban, like we're banning Djokovic, you know,
it's, it's like, there's a lot of banning going on.
It's like, to me, like,
Djokovic was banned from Australia
for the Australian Open he's banned for here,
I don't agree with his take on vaccines.
I don't agree with it at all.
I think it's a mistake.
I think he has shown some behavior
that is questionable at times during this thing.
But banning him,
But to me,
he's the greatest he's,
he's, he's arguably the best ever.
If you're, if you're running the tennis competition,
like you can't tell me that the guy,
it's not like, he's the number one ranked person,
and he is just a new guy,
he's been around for a long time.
He's made a lot of these people a lot of money.
He's, he's great for the sport,
and you can't make a special exception
for one of the greatest of all time?
See, I, I'm, I, personally, I understand rule of law,
but if, I think we can make exceptions
for the greatest of us, I think, I think we can.
I think we can.
You're such an elitist.
That's not, is that elitism?
Is that elitist? I'm not, I'm not saying it.
Elitism is...
The greats,
the greats can break the rules, Adam.
That's what you're saying.
I'm saying.
See, now we're, now we're like
tip toeing into the culture war.
I'm not saying the greats
You can't stay away from this.
I know. I'm not saying the greats can break the rules.
I'm saying that there should be...
That's exactly What you're saying.
No I'm saying there should be exceptions
to certain rules for exceptional human beings.
Right. Which is,
that's inherently by definition an elitist statement.
But I'm, but I'm not one of those people.
No, I just believe this thing, but I'm not that.
Okay, here we are.
Let's cut that out guys.
Look...
Let's cut all that.
It's slippery slope
right back into Alex Jones and Mar-a-Lago.
Yeah.
Here we are again,
no matter what we try to do.
You can say it is, say that,
anything you want about me going to Mar-a-Lago,
and hanging out with Alex Jones,
but, like you wouldn't take that invitation.
Well, just out of pure fascination,
you would have to, right?
Folks I did not go to Mar-a-Lago to dine with.
It's a brunch without,
I don't even like brunch.
I hate brunch.
Okay. One last person to vet, vet, fet, to fet?
Yeah. One last person.
We gotta, we gotta take an Ad break here in a second so.
Antonio Arguedas.
Yes.
Is Stanford great.
Unbelievable, this guy.
Your fellow Stanford alum.
This guy just completed what is called the 40 bridges,
for those not in the know, who aren't following
the day, day by day ins and outs of, of marathon swimming,
the 40 bridges is, is, is the double Manhattan swim.
It's basically swimming all the way around Manhattan twice.
It's 91.8 kilometers. In other words, 42 miles,
he just did it, and not only did he do it,
he's not the first to do it.
Like they've...
No.
The 40 bridges is a thing.
Like many people have done it,
but he did it in less than 20 hours.
And he's the oldest person to have ever done it.
How old is he? He's in his 60s.
63.
Yeah 63.
Wow.
And he, he did, he's the oldest to do the Ocean Seven,
which are the, you know, the seven great crossings.
He's the oldest to do that,
and he did that at 58 years old.
I wrote about him for the New York times there,
and then later he came and approached me.
I, I helped him write his book, Forever Swim,
which is, was originally published in Spanish,
and now is, is available in English as well,
and this last few years,
he's been focused on doing the Double Triple Crown.
So he did double Catalina, oldest to do that,
tried to do double English last year,
and was like three to five miles maybe at the most
from, from doing it.
And it just, he got caught in one of those tides
and he couldn't go, and it just got cold,
and he got hypothermic and they pulled him,
and he was literally a couple of miles or something,
I forget what it was, but he saw,
I mean, he was there near Dover,
and so that's tough,
but did he let that push him back?
No, he does this, he's already,
he's already got a boat ready
for Double English again in 2024.
Yeah. Good for him.
So he is gotta figure out what he's doing.
It's crazy when you see this guy,
he's like, he's a big burly, you know, barrel chested guy.
Like these...
Barrel-bodied?
Open water, yeah.
Open water guys are always very robust.
He calls it his bioprint.
(both laughing)
You gotta have that.
You gotta put on, you know, you gotta get like you,
you gotta get the whale blubber gun
if you're gonna go and do these things,
for flotation and for, and for maintaining core body temp.
Yeah. He trains in Los Aztecas.
Los Aztecas, Aztecas?
A river outside Mexico City, where he trains.
He also trains in the pool,
he lives in Mexico city
and really great, fun, amazing intellectual type guy.
And anyway, always fun.
Always has mariachis at the end,
yet he found some mariachis to party with at the end,
and so that's fun.
It's on his Instagram.
It's such a cool accomplishment,
and yet, you know, here we are talking about it.
There's no press on this.
No.
I Googled it, there's not one.
I mean, there's an article,
like Steven Matatonus did a piece
saying that he was going to do it.
And it was an article about the various competitors
who were gonna tackle the 40 bridges,
but not one article was written about the results or,
you know, what he had accomplished.
I couldn't pitch him because,
I couldn't bring it to New York Times,
because we covered him, when he did Ocean Seven.
So it's unclear if they would've done it again anyway,
and also because I collaborated with him on his book,
it's kind of,
I can't really now...
You can't.
Pitch stories on him, cause I know him too well.
Yeah.
We're friends.
Though not my point.
So much, so much for me
ever being in the New York Times ever again.
I mean, it's not gonna be from me, pal.
All right?
Yeah.
All right. Let's take a break.
Let's make that clear.
Let's take a break and we'll be back
with whatever we're back with.
(gust of wind blows)
(upbeat music plays)
Prophets Walk Among Us,
as a writer and podcaster for nearly 10 years,
I've become more convinced than ever,
that our world is populated
by scores of beautiful and brilliant people
who have amazing stories to share,
those that we don't know who can teach us something new
and leave us all the better
for the experience of their sharing,
and so I've dedicated my career,
to tracking down the most compelling prophets on the planet,
going deep with each of them on my podcast
to elucidate the best of what they have to offer
and to sharing the insights gleaned for the benefit of all.
But the podcast is not the only medium
by which to share their stories,
which is why I'm proud to announce
the release of my new book.
Voicing Change Volume II.
More than mere words on paper,
Voicing Change, is a physical manifestation of the magic,
inspiration and timeless wisdom
that transpires each week on the Rich Roll Podcast.
The first edition of Voicing Change
was a beautifully rendered book,
worthy of display on any coffee table,
and Volume II, follows in that tradition
by showcasing even more of my favorite conversations
in an elegant publication
replete with interview excerpts, essays,
and stunning photography,
making for an exquisite companion
to the first volume, or a satisfying standalone book.
Picking up this book,
allows you to revisit the wisdom
of your favorite everyday prophets
and physically interact
with the life changing ideas contained in the book.
Voicing Change Volume II,
available now while supplies last for a limited time,
order your copy today only at richroll.com.
(gust of wind blows)
I feel like our, our energy is good.
We, we have good flow.
Is it just because we haven't done it in a while?
I'm just happy to see you.
You know, I have that effect on a lot of people.
I call it rapport.
And everywhere I go, I try to cultivate rapport.
Did you come up with that word?
Sometimes, sometimes rapport doesn't,
is not reciprocated initially.
Yeah.
But give me time,
I will build rapport, whether you like it or not.
All right. Well, let's,
let's continue to cultivate that my friend.
That's good.
I love, I love sweet rapport.
Once again,
we are resisting the impulse to partake in the culture wars,
as we are not gonna talk about Donald Trump,
we are not gonna talk about Alex Jones,
who we are gonna talk about, is one Rainn Wilson.
Dwight Schrute from The Office.
Why are we talking about this, Adam?
Because you put a video up, a highlight,
a highlight reel,
you're doing these cool clips now,
you're doing these highlight clips,
on your, on your Instagram,
which I, I love, by the way,
they also go, do you have a TikTok?
Are they going on TikTok too?
They're going on TikTok too.
Although I don't have anything to do with TikTok.
Okay.
AJ, AJ manages that.
But tell people how this all started,
because like, I think people would be interested why,
because you've just kind of launched these and, and,
obviously people are loving 'EM,
but so tell us how that all started.
So, so when I,
when I had COVID for the second time.
Yeah.
And I was lying in bed all day, bored outta my mind.
I just thought like,
my relationship to Instagram has always been
relatively cavalier, like yeah,
I throw up pictures from the latest podcast.
I always make announcements about, you know,
who's on the show,
but beyond that, like, I don't treat it like a business.
It's sort of like I post, when I feel like it,
and I just don't want to be beholden to it
or feel like it's an onerous thing,
but while I was lying in bed,
I was like, and so I probably was posting,
I post once a week or twice a week or something like that,
but I'm lying in bed and we have all this content,
coz for every episode,
we generate all these videos
and we have all these assets
and I end up sharing like a tiny fraction
of what we actually have historically going back
over like, you know, hundreds of episodes,
and I thought, well, I'm just here.
I wonder what would happen if I just bled the feed
and just like posted three times a day, like, why not?
Let's just see what happens.
So I started doing that, particularly video,
coz I know that Instagram is favoring that right now,
and there's a lot of shifts in, you know,
their algorithm and what they're serving up to people
and people are disgruntled about that
and you can be angry
and wish that Instagram was different than it is.
Or you can just be like,
well this is what's happening right now.
Let's see what happens if I just get on board with that
and start, you know, sharing what, what they're favoring.
And so I did that,
and these videos ended up getting a lot of views
and we added like 100,000 new followers
to the Instagram account in like two weeks,
like the growth was ridiculous.
And the thing about it is,
if the algorithm doesn't like the video,
then no one sees it anyway.
So it's not like why is rich posting so many videos?
Right.
So from that experience, we sort of came back and said,
well, let's really prioritize this.
How can we elevate
the aesthetic of the reels that we're showing,
so we're distinguishing ourselves,
and, and really presenting
the wisdom of the podcast guests
in the most elegant way possible?
And the team specifically, Dan, you know,
came up with this new design,
which I'd love and is beautiful,
and people seem to enjoy.
And some of these videos,
have gone on to do millions of views,
but the one video that is the real viral outlier,
is this clip from the podcast that I did
with Rainn Wilson and Reza Aslan,
where Rainn goes on a bit of a jaunt
about how to spend your time as a 20 something,
basically saying...
Right.
That, you know, young people, college-aged people,
are overly concerned with their future
and super stressed out and are having, you know,
higher rates of depression, et cetera,
because of the pressures incident
to try and to figure out what to do with your life,
and his message was basically like, don't sweat it.
Like your 20s are for experimentation,
they're for going out in the world,
gathering experiences,
and not worrying about your career trajectory,
and just enjoying your life,
while you don't have a lot of ties or,
or responsibilities or obligations,
and so, maybe we should just play the video,
cause it's just a quick clip.
Your 20s are a waste of time.
Like don't even worry about it,
don't try and get it figured out.
Like you're, the point of your 20s
is to try 12 different things and fail at nine of them,
but truthfully in society right now,
you talk to so many college kids
and they're so depressed at 2021, coz they don't,
they haven't gotten the perfect internship over the summer
and they're not, pre-enrolled in the perfect grad program
and they don't have their, you know,
their, their job aligned.
Now I know it's hard to make a living out there.
You know, it's hard to have a career and make a living,
it's much harder than in the 80's and 90's
when we were, you know, getting our educations,
but nonetheless, if you view the 20s as a workshop stage,
then it gives you some, you can relax a little bit.
That video has as of the moment of this recording,
accumulated 20.7 million views.
So it's been viewed more than any other piece of content
I've ever shared on the internet.
And the reason that I'm bringing it up,
isn't for that purpose,
is isn't just because it was viral,
it's because the comment section here was so evenly split.
On the one hand, you had people saying,
"Yes, absolutely. I agree.
This is what I did during my 20s,
and I had such an enriching experience
and it informed everything that I do today
and I wouldn't trade it for anything,"
matched by an equally loud number of people saying,
"This is the worst advice ever."
Right.
Like what a privileged,
you know, white, old man, you know,
I, I, I, I just, you know, this is, this is like,
you don't understand my lot in life.
You, you, you have no idea how hard it is right now,
et cetera.
And I just thought that that was super interesting,
to see that divide.
And I don't have the demographics on the divide.
Right.
But I would suspect that the people who are disputing this
are, are either young people
who are having a really hard time right now,
or are people who have just, you know,
struggled in, you know, sort of dire circumstances
to like make their way in the world.
Yep. And what's your take on it?
Do you side with team Rainn or?
As a cisgender, you know, privileged white male, you know,
I mean I share Rainn's perspective.
I, I did not take that advice as a young person.
I was one of those people who was very stressed out
and career oriented, and now looking back,
I wish that I had spent my time in my 20s
to really figure out who I wanted to be.
And the only way that you can do that
is by trying lots of things and failing at them,
and having many, many, many experiences
and not worrying so much about the ladder
of your career trajectory.
And this is something that's been echoed by
lots of wise people that I've had on the podcast,
perhaps most notably by like Steven Pressfield,
who had a million jobs,
like was in the military, and mopped floors.
And I don't even know, you know, like a,
just a whole bunch of jobs that put him, you know,
in communities of people
that he wouldn't have otherwise met,
put him in circumstances and environments
that were very different from what he was used to.
And I think when you do that, you become a more, you know,
kind of robust individual,
you understand different walks of life,
different perspectives.
You start to figure out what you enjoy doing,
and what you don't enjoy doing.
It's hard to intellectualize that,
like you have to go into the world and do things to find out
like, "Oh, that that's not what I thought it was.
It's not for me,"
or "Wow, this thing I never thought of before,
like has led me into this other direction,
which is fantastic."
And I think to put a button on that thought, you know,
the person who comes to mind is, is David Epstein,
who wrote this wonderful book, Range,
that I talk about constantly on the podcast,
and his whole thesis is that
when you canvas exceptional performers
across all facets of expertise,
from science to art and sports and business, et cetera,
the people who are truly exceptional,
are generally people who have done the very thing
that Rainn is talking about,
done many, many, many things
over the course of their careers
that end up creating this very unique set of skills
that unbeknownst to them,
makes them perfectly suited to be doing the thing
that they excel at later in life.
And I think there's something really cool about that,
and interesting, now, when you're 20 years old,
and you're going out into the world,
and you're trying to make a living
and stand on your own two feet,
it's hard to hear that, right?
Because it is harder now than it used to be,
and it's not 1988, when I got outta college, 1989,
it's a very different world.
It's much more competitive.
And there is this increase in wealth inequality,
this, this, you know,
exacerbating gap between the Haves and the Have Nots.
And there's a lot more have nots than there are haves,
and the haves are getting fewer and fewer
and the middle class has completely disappeared.
So it does, I do understand why it would
land as quite indulgent to say,
"Go fuck off for 10 years and travel the world,"
but I do think if you can find a way to do that
and not worry, like, like live as leanly as possible,
like don't like, you know, don't pay rent somewhere,
like try to find a way to make ends meet and you know,
live a bit of a pauper's lifestyle
so that you can have experiences,
that is a gambit that I support.
Yeah. I mean, I, I used to know people that...
And this is your life too,
but like we're older white guys, so to understand.
Well I think maybe part of.
Difference what it is now.
I think part of the blow back, is he's like,
"Treat your 20s as a workshop stage."
He meant it. But you know,
that shows a perspective of looking back,
but when you're in your 20s,
the pressures feel so real that it, you can't,
it's hard to look at your life as a workshop stage.
No one really looks at their life that way.
And they're like the, the clock's ticking,
I'm getting behind.
Except in retrospect, but he's not wrong.
I agree with what he's saying,
but in, in a way,
all of life is a workshop stage.
You know, like the way I look at it,
is all of life is a workshop stage.
It's about getting to know yourself
and be your yourself and be your best self.
To me, that's what it's about.
Right. I think his, sorry to step on your words,
but when he said your 20s are a waste of time,
that's like the first thing he says in the clip.
And I think that's being misconstrued.
Right.
Like, he's not really saying they're a waste of time,
he's just saying, "Don't sweat it."
Like, "Don't worry about it,"
it's like what, what you do now,
isn't mission critical
to what you're gonna be doing in your 30s.
And, and so the only thing I push back on, is it is,
but it's not linear.
It's different in a way,
it's not in a way that you think.
It's nonlinear.
Not in a way that you can,
You can can't quantify it.
And you do have to be like,
there's control issues that come into play too.
Like you kind of have to be a little faith based.
Like, I know I'm like mopping a floor, you know,
in, in, in some, you know, some, you know,
diner in Ecuador right now,
but you know,
this will actually be informative later in life
in a way that I don't know.
Or just, it's a fucking crazy experience.
Right.
Like, how am I, this guy from Santa Monica,
mopping a floor in Equador? This is fucking wild.
Like what is going on right now?
It's almost like the,
we talk about wokeness, what about awakeness? You know?
Like what about being awake to the experiences you're having
and not necessarily looking at them as this,
something that's going to accumulate and then benefit me
as if that's what we're always looking for,
"How is this going to benefit me?"
What if, what if it's benefiting you
in just the experience of it?
Now that's not to say there isn't,
there aren't dark experiences that can help you,
but are not that fun to celebrate while they're happening,
cause there are, and you know, I've had my share,
and there's a lot more that I haven't had,
but I do think that this idea,
what he's saying is correct, that,
what he's saying is, there is no such thing,
he says, 20s are a waste of time, but what he,
I think what he's hinting at is,
there's no such thing as wasted time.
So if you go out and have a good time and experiment
and do things you didn't think you would get into,
or that don't necessarily add up in a linear way,
it's, it's to your benefit later
when it all starts to crystallize.
And so, I agree with him.
I think the semantics is where people got,
got missed and in terms of like the wealth inequality
and how that plays into it,
I find that really interesting
because we were talking about this
and just, we kind of came in a, in a loop
back to an article I shared with you on Defector,
which Defector is, is the place that a lot of the people
from Deadspin migrated to.
Yeah. I had never been to the Defector website before.
I believe that Drew Magary
and like, and like all these, these writers,
after Deadspin went down
in the wake of the whole Gawker thing, right?
They created their own kind of reporter owned thing,
called The Defector.
Kelsey McKinney, one of the founders,
co-founders of The Defector wrote this great piece.
The Money Is all, Is In All The Wrong Places,
and it's about wealth inequality,
but through the lens of Sydney Sweeney,
the actress from Euphoria and White Lotus,
her career, basically.
She's using her career as this lens
to then explore wealth inequality,
and it's about Sydney, Sydney's interview.
I think it was in Vanity or Hollywood Reporter, I forget,
where she...
It might be Vanity Fair.
Was it, was it?
Might be Vanity Fair?
Lemme look, go ahead.
And it was about, she kind of like comparing...
Hollywood Reporter.
Hollywood Reporter,
and it was an interview
and it kind of compared Sydney to some of her peers
who come from kind of legacy households.
Sydney grew up, she was not wealthy from Spokane Washington
when they moved to,
they all lived in a motel in LA,
while she was trying to make it in Hollywood,
and she does not come from money.
And it's about how she's used her Instagram.
If you go on her Instagram, you see she's,
she's making deals and she's always working.
And part of that reason is that,
this era of stars is not, you know, gilded
as much as this, eras before them,
because of the way things are.
And, and what Kelsey's getting at,
is because of the way the money has filtered up top.
And it's not even,
even the stars aren't making what they used to.
And so if that's true, what, what about everybody else?
What about writers?
And she goes on to talk about
Ernest Hemingway used to make $1 a word in the 30's.
Sometimes I make less than that today.
You know, like I'm obviously not Ernest.
That would be equivalent to $21 a word.
$21.
In today's economy.
Right. I think I made...
And nobody makes that.
Nobody makes that.
She's saying she's never known anyone
make more than $3 a word, I think, she's saying.
I've made, I think I've made three,
three bucks a word once, you know,
two bucks a word was like the top,
that I always, that I always wanted to get,
but often now with, with all these different places
to sell your, your writing,
I still only go to kind of a tried and true place
I've always, I've always gone to
cause I like those outlets,
but also because I'm just used to going to editors I know.
They, those prices have come down,
but there's more opportunities.
So a lot of people now,
it's easier in a way to get published than it ever was,
but you're getting paid a lot less,
you know, instead of a buck 50, or a buck,
you're getting 50 cents or less.
And so, and so she talks about that
and she has this great line,
"The shadow of our destiny is racing towards us,
a promise that meritocracy was a lie,
and that we all live in
and with the stagnant reality of that,
there's a dread building,
a bleakness that is already casting a shadow on the future.
Maybe you feel it."
Hmm.
I think meritocracy was always a lie,
but it's an interesting question about like,
where this is all leading.
So that's the article anyway.
Yeah. I mean, what's,
what's sort of interesting and compelling about this,
is that, it's a,
it's a diatribe on wealth inequality
through like the parlance of the internet,
because it's a hot take, right?
Like Sweeney, is somebody who got piled on
because in this Hollywood Reporter piece,
she was saying like,
"Look, I'd like to have a baby
and I can't take off from work,"
Right.
While she lives in a $3 million mansion.
So she's not exactly a sympathetic,
No.
Candidate for a discussion around wealth inequality,
and, and, you know,
curiously McKinney takes this perspective
that like, this is, her point is valid,
which is that the artists
are not being adequately compensated for the art.
And it's not that art
isn't making as much money as it always had.
If, if anything, it's generating more wealth,
but that wealth is being increasingly
more and more accumulated
by the people who sit behind large desks
and have no connection to the actual creation of the art.
It's the executives, right?
And it used to be, it's always been that way, right?
But it used to be,
and they used the example of Jennifer Aniston,
like you're on a hit show and it's syndicated,
and then you have passive income for life,
and you create generational wealth.
And now in the streaming era,
it doesn't work that way anymore.
And although Sweeney,
who's one of the top performers in her age bracket,
and certainly a star on the rise,
who works all the time,
and is, and is being well compensated for that,
feels like she has to be on her hustle game all the time
and has to leverage her Instagram for Ads,
in a way that these other people don't
and is criticized for that,
but she comes from humble beginnings
and sort of feels like,
"This is what I have to do in order to,"
you know, kind of, you know,
"Be who I want to be in the world," right?
And, and the point being made by McKinney is,
regardless of if you're wealthy or not,
or whatever your lifestyle is,
like everybody deserves to be able to take time off
to have a baby.
And in this modern age of increased wealth disparity,
when the CEOs in the top brass are just making, you know,
outlandish amounts of money
and the people who are actually generating,
you know, the, the,
the actual things that are creating that wealth,
are being less and less respected for that.
Like that's problematic,
in terms of how our society can cohere long term.
And, you know, it's like,
another example would be like looking at LeBron,
like he makes an unbelievable amount of money,
but when you look at how much money the NBA generates,
like, there's certainly a very good argument
that you could make that he should be paying
10 times what he is getting paid.
Right. Right.
And, and, and when those guys take commercial deals,
no one's really criticizing it.
And, and, and, and, you know,
when you hear George Clooney or Matt Damon on a Ad,
no one's criticizing them.
Right. Like when Matt Damon does the Ad for crypto,
for crypto.com.
He actually he did get,
He got dragged a little bit for that,
especially when crypto he did plumed.
He did, he did.
But yeah. But like, yeah,
you see a basketball player doing a Mountain Dew Ad,
or a Sprite Ad, it's like, yeah, that's what you do, right?
Right. It's part of the business.
But somehow,
that doesn't apply to people's Instagrams in the same way.
I also think it's like, how people have like,
acclimated to that personality.
Like there's like the Kardashians
use their Instagram to sell stuff all the time, right?
Right.
I don't do that.
And occasionally I have branded deals with podcast sponsors
that require a social post here and there.
And when I do that, like, it's,
it doesn't go over as well.
But why is that?
Right.
You know.
well, I mean, I think first of all,
just to clarify a couple things, cause I kind of, when I, I,
I feel like I kind of made a mess
of introducing this article,
but listen, nobody cries for Hollywood Creators,
especially people who are Emmy Nominated Actors
who seem to have it going on,
no one cries for writers, nor should they, by the way,
like we make this choice to go into the business.
I don't, I don't feel like I'm entitled to anything.
But it shouldn't be like, you're welcoming, martyrdom.
No, no, no.
When you look at like Ernest Hemingway,
who lived in beautiful places all over the world
to be the writer that he was.
He was the most popular novelist at the time in the 30's
when he was getting that, that money,
but, and he was selling mag, you know,
I'm not, I'm not defending how little we make now,
because that's ridiculous.
Like we should, our, our, we, it is not equitable.
But, but what, I guess what I'm trying to say is,
it was never easy.
You know, I had this conversation with Elizabeth Gilbert,
back, way back in the day when I was struggling,
and I'm like, God, like, it used to be so much easier.
Like you think about, that it was so much easier.
You, you gotta feature,
you could write five features for a magazine a year
and make a living.
Right.
And, and, and pay mortgage.
Like spend three or four months on a Vanity Fair piece.
Right. That's what I'd always thought,
and then Eli... and then Liz said,
"It was always hard. It was never fucking easy."
Like no one told, asked us to do this.
So like, I'm not down with the, you know,
you see it all the time on Twitter,
writers complaining about their editors,
or complaining about how I'm being treated.
However, the great Tom Stoddart, photographer,
I worked with once and who I speak to as a friend...
Not to be confused with Tom Stoppard.
No. He had this desk fuckwit theory.
And it was all about like,
the people in the office don't know what we go through.
And then they, you know, make edits or criticize,
and he called them the desk fuckwits.
These are really the desk fuckwits,
not the people that, that are editing,
but the people who are at the very, very top,
the, the, the, the, those are the real desk fuckwits.
And they are making too much money,
and the rich aren't being taxed enough.
And because of that,
we don't have six months parenting leave in this country,
while there're, certain countries have it, you know,
like I think at Austria,
both parents can take six months at least off,
and so we don't have that,
and it's because of the way our society functions.
So it's a lens to look at that,
and it does affect journalism, because then you get,
it's a star, it's basically a star factory now.
And so now you have star journalists that go out,
leave their publications,
and then are now competing with their publications
and their own business, right?
You had a couple examples.
And they, what do they end up doing,
leaning into these culture war topics.
Right.
Because they can make money that.
Because the incentive structure,
so heavily weights and favors that type of discourse,
and people are wildly rewarded for engaging in that.
Yeah.
Which makes, you know, exempting yourself
from becoming a profiteer in the culture war
all the much harder, right?
Because the temptation lives there.
And it's so interesting to look
like just in the journalism context, you know,
setting aside, okay, here,
we have this article about Sweeney
and she uses her Instagram, you know, for advertising.
And, you know, what does that say more broadly,
about people who are, you know,
kind of leveraging the internet to make a living,
like if you're gonna step outside the enclave
of the studio movie making business,
or the newsrooms of print journalism,
to be an online personality, whether it's, you know,
Glenn Greenwald, or Matt Taibbi,
or some of these other very prominent people,
who have left the protective, you know,
cone of their, of their, of their publications,
to create subs, sub stacks,
then it becomes a situation in which
you have to garner subscribers, how do you do that?
You have to, you have to attract attention to yourself.
Well, how do you attract attention to yourself?
Is it by writing, you know,
long form nuanced articles about how complex everything is?
No, it's about having a hot take,
that will be a flashpoint in the public discourse
that will draw eyeballs to you
and activate people into subscribing.
And so whether or not
these are people acting in good faith or not,
and you can have a debate about that.
The incentive structures are so powerful
to drive people to create that type of content,
that it creates a different form of, you know,
quote unquote journalism altogether.
And that's the kind of information landscape
that we find ourselves in now.
And some people are well suited to, you know,
participating in that ecosystem
and adhering to their value set
and staying true to their journalistic principles
and others aren't, and for those that aren't,
I'm almost sympathetic towards them,
because the economics of this,
are driving behavior in such a powerful way,
that it almost becomes impossible to resist.
And this is something that I think a lot about
as a podcaster with a platform,
like who are the people that I want to have on the show.
Like I know if I get, you know,
if I invite Jordan Peterson on the show,
that would probably get a lot of views and a lot of listens,
but it's not somebody I'm interested in, in, in talking to,
like, I, I, I just,
so I's like a constant reminder of like,
"Okay, why am I doing this?
Who are the people that I value and that I wanna celebrate?
Who are the people that I think
I can have the most interesting, compelling conversations
that are most helpful to the audience,"
and really trying to make sure
that I'm staying true to that directive,
in the midst of, you know,
economic temptations that exist out there,
that I think are pulling content creators
in all kinds of directions that, you know,
are leading a lot of people, you know, good people astray.
These are so interesting points,
and when you're talking about it,
you're, in thinking of it as the economics,
as the big magnet,
that's pulling everything into these different directions,
or the many magnets that are kind of pulling it all apart.
I think of that Ezra Klein article that we also read.
The medium Really Is the Message,
kind of goes into Marshall McLuhan,
and, and it talks about, you know,
it goes back into these thinkers and philosophers
who we're looking at television
and way television impacted culture,
and then he takes that and, and goes into the internet,
and, and obviously what goes unmentioned
in this article is the phone,
but the idea is, the medium itself is actually the magnet.
The medium is what's driving us to this.
It's, what's driving, you know,
Sydney Sweeney to feel like
she has to make that extra money
in, in whatever way she can.
It's what's driving the writer to like,
to write about it and comment on it.
It's, it's driving the, the,
the wealth inequality.
Right.
It's driving all of it.
The medium itself is doing that.
The medium is, is, is, is what's taken, you know,
Glenn Greenwald, or Matt Taibbi and, and pushed them into,
into reporting in the ways that they're reporting now.
It's not a criticism of, of either.
I, I never really was a fan of the way,
Glenn Greenwell conducted himself and wrote his stuff.
I never liked his stuff, really.
Matt Taibbi, love his stuff, always have,
but they both have followed this kind of pattern
of going from the left now kind of...
So, you know, going to the other side,
and only questioning the left,
and they keep hitting that drum and beating that drum.
Why? I don't know.
I don't know what's happening in their business world,
but you're making the question.
Maybe it's because of this incentive and it is probably,
but maybe it's also,
the incentive comes from the medium itself.
Well, there's the incentive,
and then there is, you know,
the response to the content
and the kind of external audience validation
that plays into the, you know,
not just partisanship, but the true acrimony, right?
And when you appeal to a certain group
and then you're then championed by that group,
it's it's then, you know,
sort of de facto that you're going to feel
like you want to continue to please that group, right?
Which is antithetical to, you know, journalistic ethics.
Right, right, right, right, right.
And it is a weird, you know,
kind of undefined space in which,
it's unclear whether this is journalism,
is this opinion piece, does it matter?
Should it matter?
Like, what is this?
It, it totally matters.
Like we have way too much opinion in the news.
Why do we do that?
Is it because we're, like everyone wants like,
someone talking to 'EM at the camera,
everyone wants a certain tone? Is it, is it...?
And could we ever find ourselves
moving back towards an objective news landscape?
Like, I, I don't think so.
No. I mean, this,
you don't put genies back in the bottle, right?
So the only way is for you then to curate your own life
and like I'm only gonna read...
And that's problematic in its own in its,
in its own regard.
It is. I mean, it's always been there, right?
Do I want to tune in to this outer world
and the strife that's going on
or do I not want to,
and, and you gotta find strike that balance,
but the, I think the medium being the message,
if you look at it that way,
the problem isn't really Matt Taibbi, Glenn,
streaming, the desk fuckwits, whatever,
the problem is that we are being driven by this technology
in a, in ways that are not necessarily good for
the micro, the self, or society, the whole.
And so, you know, we it's,
it's used that way, but, but it's viewed that way.
This has all been an advancement.
This is great. This is great. It's not true.
You know, some, some stuff is not great,
and there's a good art,
a good point in the Ezra piece about,
is it Jonathan Height?
Yeah.
He, he wrote about how, there's no fix for,
for a platform that allows
teenage girls who are going through puberty
to post photos of themselves.
You know, basically...
Yeah.
Like, you know,
looking for approval essentially, and it's...
I mean, Height has been really great
on this subject matter.
It's subject matter that I think is incredibly important.
And I know it's come up many times on this podcast,
but I, I'm becoming more and more convinced that it is,
you know, a great existential threat to humanity.
Yeah.
In, in, in, in so many ways.
And you know, I think Jonathan Height's work on this
is really important.
Of course, Tristan Harris,
who I'm hoping to get on the podcast soon,
Johann Hari's recent book about his struggle with the phone,
and this new book that I'm about to read,
called The Chaos In The Machine by Max Fisher,
who's a New York Times writer,
New York Times reporter, and Pulitzer Prize finalist,
on the, on this very subject matter,
the inside story of how
social media rewired our minds and our world,
and he's coming on next week.
So I gotta get through this book in the next week,
but I'm glad that smart people are thinking about this,
but I feel strongly that we should all be really thinking
about this and considering it profoundly
because it is profound.
Yeah. And like,
we don't all have to take every deal, you know?
We don't have to make the most,
like, that's the thing also.
You know I'm just gonna keep throwing reels
up on Instagram.
Yeah. Because that's what the market wants.
Right.
But there's a point in here, that.
It's like, I'm, I'm a hypocrite.
We're all, that's...
You know?
That's the new, that's the modern world.
We are all hypocrites, but interesting in some ways.
You know, we we're coming at you in
ones and zeros on the internet.
Right.
And I've made a, you know, a, a living doing this.
So it's complicated, man.
Me too. I was the biggest critic of Amazon until,
you know, I wrote David Book,
and that's the only place we can really sell it.
And, and you know, it's in bookstores too.
Yeah. Amazon has, is basically, yeah,
played a huge part in you being able to...
That's the reason I was able to give up half my shifts
at Ben & Jerry's.
Right.
The, he said, one thing about how,
like the medium impacts our attention.
Obviously we know that, right?
It's an attention, it's an attention economy.
We're all, we're all like,
either donating our attention, or hoing for attention,
excuse my, my language.
But it does affect how you function,
and I never read several books at once except in college,
and now I've, I've got like five books going, you know,
and I'll tell you, like some of it's work related research,
some of it's fiction that I wanna read.
Some of it's like, non-fiction I know I should know,
Some of it, it's Flea.
You know what I mean.
Acid for the Children.
I actually, yes. I actually really like it.
That's what's funny.
Is it actually actually liberating.
I don't see you juggling five books as problematic though.
No, but I never did before.
This is not a an issue.
No, but I think it shows...
But your life's different than,
your life is different than it was before.
Am I making this about me again?
No, I, I, I mean,
are you trying to make the argument
that you're lapsing into some kind of attention deficit
driven by internet culture?
Yes.
And that's why, yeah.
I don't, I don't really see that.
No?
I don't see the connective tissue
between those two things.
I think if you were saying,
I'm struggling to sit down and read
for more than 10 minutes at a time without getting antsy,
that would be more in line.
Okay. Retracted.
Yeah.
Retracted.
But the fact that you're reading,
you're like, yeah, it's terrible.
I'm reading five books right now.
Like most people have trouble getting through one book.
Right.
Because they're so distracted.
So you do you bro.
Sorry guys. That was, that was like one of those,
like one of those, like you, you you're,
you're like, you're patting yourself on the back
by criticizing yourself.
Yeah.
(both laughing)
A humble brag?
Humble brag.
It's so terrible.
I'm reading five books at once right now.
I can't believe I've read so well this week.
And holding down four shifts at,
at the, at the Ben & Jerry's,
And raising a...
And writing books.
And, and raising a, a, a Spanglish speaking child.
Right. Adios, adios, Adam to that discussion.
Sometimes audios is, is, is Gentle.
It's like audios. I, I'm, I'm needed elsewhere.
Sometimes it's, sometimes it's,
"Adios I'll see you next time."
Sometimes it's, "Adios."
Clint Eastwood style.
Yeah. Like a snarl.
All right.
What are we doing?
We gotta get to listener questions.
Let's do it.
One thing I will point out though.
Yeah.
There was a great long read,
very long read in the New York Times.
I mean, I'm talking like,
I think it would take an hour and a half
to read this whole article.
It would take most,
most people wouldn't finish it quite frankly.
Right.
But I love it.
It's called Willie Nelson's Long Encore.
It's a beautiful article with amazing photographs about,
you know, this legend Willie Nelson,
who's now approaching 90 and is still touring like crazy,
is still very much, you know, in his creative juices,
he put out nine albums in the past five years.
And I just think on the heels of
the Mike Fremont podcast coming out and, and, you know,
on the subject of like rethinking aging,
and, and embracing longevity and what we're truly capable of
the fact that this, you know, beautiful artist, you know,
is still out on the road and like putting music out,
like there's no tomorrow is something cool to be celebrated.
I mean, he's truly a national treasure.
I didn't realize that he was that old, he's 89 now.
Yeah.
And he's got emphysema
and is still singing and playing shows.
That's crazy.
I know.
Shout out to Steve Tip,
my boy Steve Tip for recommending this read,
and yeah, no dimming of his creative light.
No, that, that, that makes me feel a little better.
Which is very inspiring.
That makes me glad I took Rainn's advice,
and, and wasted my 20s, 30s, and 40s,
because it means I still have a lot to go, a lot.
Yeah. I mean, what do you think,
like if Willie Nelson sat down
and looked at that Rainn Wilson clip,
what do you think Willie Nelson would say?
He'd be like, I'm still doing that.
I know. Yeah. It's exactly what he would say.
No, I mean, he's been, he's been, you know, I,
in that article,
Willie Nelson didn't become a hit until he was 40
and didn't do his, his most critically acclaimed work
until he was 45.
So like he, he, you know, he,
he would say he agrees 100%.
Sure. Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah.
So there you go, critics.
It's always,
but the point I'm trying to make is that
he says it's harder now.
I'm not so sure.
It's always been hard. It's always been hard.
Every, yeah, but, but this time, Adam,
you don't understand.
Yeah.
It's harder. And look, it is harder.
It is a lot. I, I, I'm very sympathetic to young people.
And as somebody who, you know, who has,
I have two stepsons that are 28 and 27, like I know,
you know, I have a,
I have a pretty good sense of what it's like out there
through their shared experiences.
And it is harder, you know,
but that I don't think is worthy enough to, you know,
excuse the value of trying to figure out
a way to have adventures and experiences when you're young,
because that is the time to do it.
Yep. 100%.
Enough said. All right.
Let's go to listener questions.
Listener questions.
Adam from Fort Collins.
From Adam to Adam.
Yeah. If your name's Adam,
I'm, I'm gonna put you right to the top.
And we should say like, we need more questions.
Yes.
Please.
We need more questions guys.
We're we're, we're skipping the,
as they say the, the bottom.
We need, we need to refill the, the, the receptacle.
So leave us a message at four, two,
I don't think we've called out the number enough.
That's part of the problem.
(424) 235-4626.
That's (424) 235-4626.
Call now.
[Adam From Fort Collins] Hey, Rich and Adam.
This is Adam in Fort Collins, Colorado,
and I just wanted to know what your guys' thoughts were
when it comes to big life goals.
I'm wanting to do the Never Summer 60k next year,
by far in a way the biggest thing I have done,
and my wife thinks that
I need to really step away from that goal
for this 2023 projection and do some smaller things.
When I kind of have an accountability mirror
and every year I put something bigger on it.
And although it scares me,
I hear my wife's worries about safety
and just being realistic with time.
And how do you balance concerns of your loved ones
with family and safety and on the other side,
your dreams and your goals that are big
and sometimes dangerous,
and where does your intuition and kind of instinct
fall into all of that?
Thanks so much.
I cannot wait for every Monday,
when I see that, that little blue dot on my Spotify
for another podcast.
And yeah, I just have had my life completely changed
by the years of wonderful information
and eating a vegan diet for the past year.
It's been incredible.
Thanks so much you guys.
Have a great day.
Thank you, Adam. Great question.
Basically, this is a question about
the tension between setting big goals
and meeting family expectations,
or having to deal with prote...
perhaps not as much support as you were looking for,
in, in, in your home, and it's tricky, right?
I think the way that I would answer this is that,
first of all, like goals are super important.
Everybody should have goals.
They serve as these powerful potent light, lighthouses
to, to kind of really focus and direct your actions.
And I think big goals serve a further purpose,
which is this beautiful way
to kind of spark a deeper level of engagement
in your daily life experience,
to get out bed like energized and excited about, you know,
tackling something audacious
or something that scares you a little bit.
Like it, it really enervates you, and I thinks.
Enervate? I think energizes.
Isn't it enervate? I'm using enervate correctly.
I think enervate means you're drained of energy.
Oh, you're right.
I've done that before.
I need to really...
it's okay.
Figure that out.
Yeah. Energize.
It's the medium's fault.
Right. Thank you for correcting me.
Yeah. It's all right.
What I'm trying to say is
that big goals can help you feel like more alive, right?
Yeah. Yeah.
But I think, you know, and Adam already realizes this,
that the, these big goals have to be negotiated
with those with whom we share responsibilities,
otherwise they can quickly devolve into selfish pursuits
that end up undermining
the other important aspects of, of your life,
including, you know,
our relationship with our loved ones
and our ability to live up to our responsibilities
and our professional obligations and expectations.
And because by definition,
our time and our energy is limited,
it's not unlimited,
all of this becomes a tricky balance.
Like how do you strike the appropriate balance
between those two things?
And I think it begins by going beyond this discussion
around goals, temporal goals,
and instead getting really clear on values.
And this is something that came up
in the podcast with James Clear,
like you should read his book, Atomic Habits,
if you haven't read that,
because it talks all about this.
So, basically what I'm saying is,
starting with your values,
identifying which values you cherish most,
and there's no right or wrong answers here.
Like maybe it's your marriage,
maybe it's parenting, career, finances,
health, fitness, adventure, you know,
it's just getting clear on,
on the priority list of these things
and then figuring out like,
how are these values being most nourished daily?
And then getting granular to ask yourself if a 60K race
fits into that value set or value structure
or whether it comes at the peril
of these other values, right?
Like, does it, does it exceedingly threaten
your marriage or your relationship and then asking,
well, if it does, is it worth it?
Or is there a way to pursue this goal,
nourish these values, and keep both of them intact?
So in other words,
it's about asking yourself
whether the goal fulfills the value, right?
Why is this race important to you?
What are you seeking to learn and experience
and getting clear on like,
oh, it just seems like a cool thing,
or it scares me, like, okay,
well, let's go beneath the surface of that.
Like, why do you have to do a race to do that?
Could you do something else?
Or what specifically is it about this race,
that makes it so important
that you would desire to pursue it even if your wife
has reservations about you doing it, right?
So I think that's important.
Yes.
Would you agree with that? And then...
And then, and then with that clarity,
it becomes about communication.
Yes.
Like, okay, your wife is scared.
Well, what is she scared about?
Like, what are those fears?
Is she legitimately scared
that you're gonna injure yourself,
or does that fear have more to do with,
you not being around as much?
Or when you are around being too tired to, you know,
basically be present for her?
Like, are her fears legitimate?
Are her concerns legitimate,
or is there something that you can talk through with her
that would make her less fearful
and more welcoming of you pursuing this goal?
Coz obviously, if you're in a healthy relationship,
you want each other to be pursuing goals.
Right.
And you wanna be, you know,
mutual support systems for each other.
So, in this case she doesn't seem to be on board with it
and you can be disgruntled and angry and resentful,
or you can try to understand that
and figure out a way to compromise
so that you're both comfortable.
Because you cohabitate together
and you've gotta be on the same page
if you want your relationship to per, you know,
continue in a, in a healthy way.
And then with that understanding,
like holding yourself accountable to that,
like if you can come to some compromise where she says,
okay, you could do it, but I need to make sure that,
you know, you're still available for X, Y, and Z,
or that we're gonna do this
or that you're gonna show up for me in these other ways.
And then making sure that not only do you do that,
but you do it with a smile on your face
and perhaps you even go the extra mile
to make sure that she's feeling heard
and, and honored in that,
like, and at ease with you pursuing this goal.
And I think the final thing I would say is that, you know,
it's hard to know just based on your question,
but it seems like,
or it feels like you have different risk calculuses, right?
Like she seems to be a little bit more risk averse than you.
You want to pursue this thing that,
to me, like training for a 60K race
doesn't sound that risky.
I mean, maybe it's super technical
and you can fall off a cliff, I don't know.
It's it's, it's a minimum max elevation, 8,500 to
11, nine, average elevation 10.
It, it seems like in the Leadville category,
there's 100K and 60K. So it's not as long.
Right.
Yeah.
So maybe some risk., I don't know what,
Late July.
Risk background is and all of that kind of thing.
You want to take a risk.
She's more risk aversed.
There's no right or wrong in that.
It's totally okay,
but your relationship requires honoring each other,
so you both feel safe, heard, and respected.
So, does she have wiggle room?
Do you have wiggle room?
How can you work together
to get to a place where you're both comfortable with this?
Because you don't wanna like say,
"I'm just doing it anyway.
I don't care if you're scared."
That's not a good recipe for,
for the, the sake of your relationship,
but you also don't want to just say,
"Oh, you don't want me to do it.
I'm not gonna do it,"
coz you're just gonna get resentful towards her.
So, you know, you gotta work it out.
It's not for me to say whether you should or shouldn't
pursue this goal, only, you know, only Adam knows that,
but, but you know, that's, that's where I would leave it.
So, get granular, figure out if the goal, where.
Get global first, then get.
Get global with goals and values...
Then get granular.
And get granular,
then build a deck so that you can...
Present a Power Point.
Present it to the wife,
(both laughing)
and get her to rubber stamp that thing.
That's what you're saying?
No.
Oh no.
As someone who is raising a, a, a young person,
with, with a lovely lady.
And as somebody who likes adventures...
I'm not unfamiliar with risks.
And you like risks. Yeah.
Like this is right up your alley.
I've been, I've been, I've been dealing with this.
So, but I do find that when you can communicate
why it means something to you,
you have a better chance of, of...
The why is huge.
The, yeah. The why is huge.
You have a better chance of,
of winning people over,
but it also means that you have to show up
when it's your time and you have to, like,
you, we've talked about it.
it's in your book.
Sure.
You know, you had, like,
you have taken on some of the biggest things
you already took on, while having small kids,
and that meant that you couldn't be tired
from your 100K bike ride.
Yeah. I'd walk in the door, like completely exhausted.
Here you go.
Julie handed me a baby and said, "See ya."
Right.
Yeah.
And, and you need,
you needed to be available for that.
So, so, you know, we both know this,
and it sounds like Adam knows it too,
because he's not just like dismissing it entirely.
He's it seems like, you know, he wants to do this thing.
He wants, you know, sometimes it's like.
And maybe you work up to it.
Maybe you compromise by doing, you know,
a more modest race this year
and demonstrate your good faith.
Like you fulfilled,
you met that goal and you also were able to show up.
So then your wife has more comfort
with you tackling something else.
And perhaps she's less afraid.
Like, does this have to happen this year?
Can you work up to it a little bit more gradually?
There are seasons to life and you can't like,
maybe you used to be freer
and you could do these things a little bit easier,
but that doesn't mean that was better.
It just means you're in a different period of your life now.
And so you can't judge your current period
based on who you used to be.
You have to judge it on who you are now,
and then that period will pass
and you will be able to take on some more risk at times.
I mean, that's just the way things go.
That's how I look at it.
And so I'm not trying to like get underwater, you know,
five days a week,
cause it's unrealistic it won't happen.
If I do that, I will never work,
and you know, that's not good.
So like I had to figure out a way to make it work
and it's, and it's constant,
constant communication to continue to make it work.
And so I would just urge constant communication
and, and just getting to know your goals,
I have not done the deep dive of goals and values,
that sounds really interesting.
You know, I, I try to,
I kind of live in more of a improvisational state.
Yeah, I get that.
I like that.
I get that.
Cool. Well, let's move on.
Yeah. You're very good at these, by the way.
Thank you. That was good advice, Adam.
Really?
Mm-hmm.
You think I'll make one of those reels?
Yeah, I think so. We'll see.
This is your moment. Like you gotta throw down.
I made one. I made one.
Throw down like the dope,
this just super dope monologue
and I will for sure put it up.
What if I like brought in my own like cool music
and just hit in like a boombox.
It's time for my reel, Rich. Are you ready?
Ready for my, my reel, hang on.
I'm trying to find this next one.
I had to go deep in the archives for this.
All right, here we go.
All the way to New Zealand.
Hello there Rich and Adam.
This is Anita calling from a New Zealand.
Three years ago,
I was diagnosed with breast cancer.
I had chemo, surgery, and radio therapy.
As part of that journey,
I completely changed my lifestyle,
now I eat plant based,
I exercise regularly,
I don't drink,
I go to bed early,
and I have a spiritual practice.
So far so good.
I feel better than ever before.
I was single when I got cancer,
and for the last three years,
I've been fully dedicated to myself
to recover and to stay cancer free.
Now, I feel ready to start dating again,
but I'm finding very difficult
to find people who align to my new lifestyle.
So my question for you is,
what will you do if you were single today
and you wanted to find a new partner?
Would you be a strict
about finding someone who aligns 100% to your values,
or will you be more flexible?
Thank you guys,
I love the podcast.
I can't thank you enough for all the knowledge
and inspiration you share. Bye.
Thank you, Anita.
I'm sorry that you went through cancer,
but it sounds like you've come out the other side healthy
and that's great, of course.
It also sounds like maybe you're from Argentina
and not New Zealand.
Oh really?
It's not a New Zealand accent.
No, but she lives in New Zealand.
Yeah, she does.
Why, why Argentina?
I don't know. It's just a twang of Latin in there.
Yeah.
That reminded me of a,
a friend from that part of the world
and sounded familiar, who knows?
Was your friend named Che Guevara?
(laughing)
He was not.
Are you trying to lure me back into the culture war, Adam?
The OG culture warrior?
I am resisting. I will not be a profiteer.
Anita, so thank you for the question.
I'm probably not the best person to ask about dating,
coz I've been with my wife for 22 years,
but I will say this,
I, I, I think it's,
It's healthy and better to spend less time
focusing on the qualities of the person you're looking for.
Like identifying in your mind,
like this person that I'm looking for
has to have these things in order for me to be interested,
like to the extent that you can kind of let go of that
and instead focus more on
continuing to become the person you aspire to be.
I feel like that's a better use of your,
your energy, time,
and, and also a more powerful lever and magnet
towards attracting that person
that you're looking for into your life,
that you might not
really even be able to define and identify.
Hmm.
Because being the most developed,
authentic and self actualized that you possibly can be
is the most attractive that you can be, right?
The more that you can develop those capacities,
the more confident you are,
the more steady you are
and standing in your own two feet, right?
Tall, and, and just owning your space,
and that's something that, you know, radiates,
when you walk into a room.
You always know like,
"Oh, that person knows who they are."
Like, there's something innately very attractive about that
because we all want to be with somebody
who knows who they are and owns their space.
Yes. And if they don't know who they are...
Yeah.
That means they have amnesia
and you should not date them.
Well, I mean, you know what I saying though?
(laughing)
I'm just kidding. Yes.
Yeah. It's like this attractor,
like you put, it's a force field or a attractor beam,
that, that ends up attracting the quality of person
that you seek to have in your life.
You be, I've said this before,
but it's like, you know, imagining yourself as a lighthouse,
like you're, you're putting this signal out into the world
for those that, you know,
and those that resonate with it
will become attracted to you.
Like water rises to its own level.
So level up to attract the like-minded person.
And, and remembering, you know, this idea that like,
a partner doesn't and will never complete you.
Like that's not their job.
Your job is to complete yourself.
So it's not looking for that externality
to be the missing piece in who you are,
like do that on your own time with yourself,
and when you solve that puzzle,
then you're ready to be in the world
and attract the person that you desire into your life.
And on the, on the subject of like flexibility
and trying to identify people who, who share your values,
I think it's important that intimate partners
share core values.
The former question was kind of all about that,
like finding shared core values.
But beyond that,
I think it's important to not be too rigorous or demanding
when it comes to
how that person embodies or expresses those values.
In other words, like,
let go of rigorously, attempting to match with someone
who aligns 100% with everything you're interested in.
Like if you look at my wife and I,
we're incredibly different people, we align on values,
but we can also be like oil and water.
Like our marriage is not without friction.
Hmm.
But there's something about that Alchemy,
that's been this incredible
growth experience for both of us.
Like, her differences have pushed me to grow in ways
that I probably wouldn't have otherwise,
and hopefully I can say the same for her.
And that alchemical kind of concoction,
has been, you know,
a really beautiful aspect of our marriage.
It's, it's hard at times it makes it really hard,
but I wouldn't trade it for anything.
And had I been in a position
of just trying to find the person who met my criteria
and they need to be this person who does these things,
I would've missed the opportunity
and missed the gift, right?
Cause we're all constantly growing
and evolving all the time.
So if you're like,
my partner needs to eat exactly the way that I do,
and they need to, you know, do the da, da, da,
like, you're just setting yourself up for frustration.
So, maybe expand the aperture a little bit,
and also, you're dating, you're not getting married,
like go out and date people.
Like have fun.
If it's not, it's like, it's not a fit,
then it's not a fit.
You're right.
Like, no loss.
You had an experience meeting somebody.
It's not a failure,
it's just another experience.
100%. I'd say be flexible.
They do not have to meet 100% of your criteria.
Have fun, feel it out, explore the mystery.
It's like, it's like good creative, creative projects.
You never know where you're gonna land,
and your life is like that, right?
Even people who like you're saying,
know who they are, actually don't really,
to be honest with you,
nobody knows exactly who they are
or who they're gonna become.
And so, you don't even know
where you're gonna be in 10 years.
I'm not saying you're not gonna have certain values
that stick with you and are important to you,
what I'm saying is,
you don't know how that will evolve and evolve you.
And so, you know, just because you meet someone,
even if you're as close to 100% now,
that doesn't mean that's gonna be the case in 10 years.
Mm-hmm.
It's about, it, does the communication overlap?
Can you grow together
and allow people to grow a little bit differently?
Coz hopefully that will happen.
And, and that's gonna take being at ease in the mystery,
and doing creative projects at ease in the mystery,
you've survived cancer.
You had to figure out how to stay at ease,
in the, in the hardest mystery of all, this is dating.
And it could be hard coz you know,
when you're, when I, I, I,
we don't know how, you know, this person's life,
or Anita where, you know, how, has she been married before?
We don't know anything about it,
but, we know that,
as a single person, I know what it's like post divorce.
It is lonely sometimes.
So the mystery's not always enjoyable,
but you do have to find a way to be at ease in it.
coz like, that ease,
is going to be critical in enjoying your life,
let alone meeting a partner.
So, you know, how can you find ease in the mystery?
Mm, Adam Skolnick coming through with his reel.
What a good reel?
Oh, shit, I forgot to hit the music.
(Adam mimicking music sounds)
(Rich laughing)
You're good at that, man.
Fantastic,
I think that's a good place to wind it down for today.
All right.
Beautifully put my friend,
always good to share a space with you.
Thanks for having me.
It's good.
I feel like we got like, I feel we're connected.
We're pulled back in?
Yeah. You feel alright?
Yeah. Are we going, are we doing this again in two weeks?
Do you think anyone is still listening?
No.
Right. It's liberating, right?
Say whatever the fuck you want.
That's why I'm at my best at the end.
The stakes are low.
Stakes are low.
Right.
This doesn't matter. It's all, it's all a stage.
A what's he call it, a rehearsal stage, a...
The Rehearsal.
The rehearsal space.
Have you been watching Navy?
No. That's my list.
The Rehearsal?
It's on my list.
We'll talk about it next time.
Okay.
I just finished it last night.
All right.
It's unbelievable.
I'm too busy watching, off-label you know,
Red Hot Chili Peppers, like failed docs,
and, and Instagram.
You gotta get down with Nathan Fielder.
for day.
The Rehearsal is really quite something.
Okay.
Yeah.
I'm in.
So next time.
All right buddy?
Yeah.
Cool. I think we're back in two weeks,
if we're not give or take,
but I'm pretty sure we are.
Cool.
See everybody back here again soon,
Thanks for taking this ride with us.
You can follow Adam, @adamskolnick.
I'm @richroll, everywhere except on TikTok.
I think it's, iamrichroll.
Again, we need your questions.
Yes.
Leave us a message.
(424) 235-4626.
If you wanna check the show notes for the links
to everything that we've discussed,
visit the episode Page four, this episode,
episode 700.
Congratulations.
How about that?
At richroll.com.
And, hey, you know what,
why don't you subscribe to our YouTube channel?
Yeah.
And maybe on Apple Podcasts and Spotify,
while you're at it, just go full bore,
like you're at the buffet at a Las Vegas casino,
and you're just going all in.
Yeah. And then subscribe to the newsletter.
There you go.
And if not,
we'll subscribe you.
And then you can unsubscribe
and then subscribe again and keep on subscribing,
coz it is very gratifying to unsubscribe to newsletters.
It's so good.
I'm giving you that opportunity.
It's so good. It's so good.
Okay.
I love it.
Appreciate everybody who helps put on the show.
Adam and I do not do this alone.
Jason Camiolo, audio engineering production show notes,
interstitial music and more,
Blake Curtis and Dan Drake, for all the video work.
Daniel Solis for graphics,
AJ Aphrodite for TikToks and more,
David Greenberg and Grayson Wilder, although Grayson moved.
He's not with us as much anymore.
Where'd he move?
We've got, he moved to Tennessee.
Oh.
And now we have Giselle Peters, who's been fantastic.
Thank you Giselle for portraits.
Although we got Dan today, because none, neither,
Nobody could come.
Yeah.
So, today's photos?
Dan Drake.
On the socials, by Dan Drake,
Georgia Whaley for copywriting,
DK for advertiser relationships,
that's the engine behind all of this,
and theme music is always by my boys, Tyler and Trapper,
and my nephew, Harry.
Thanks guys for that theme song
that just refuses to go away 10 years later.
It's Good.
No matter how much I wish to move on and transcend it
and try something new, the fans have spoken.
So anyway, thanks for the love you guys.
See you back here in a couple days
with another awesome episode and until then,
take us out Adam.
Peace, plants, adios!
(Rich whispering)
Namaste.
(upbeat music playing)